All right.
Let me be sure I got everything.
Those are here.
Okay.
This is like a record for me.
Two guests in a row on a Thursday podcast.
All right,
we ready?
Yeah.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
And I'm just checking in on you.
What's going on?
How are you?
How's your week going?
That's wonderful.
Wonderful.
All right,
well once again,
two weeks in a row,
we,
uh,
we have a special guest in studio.
This is the one and only comic legend rich shiner who has a new book.
He's here to plug,
um,
that I actually got a couple months ago,
but my wife was so goddamn pregnant.
I've only been able to read bits and pieces of it.
I read all of,
I killed in 2006.
He's got a book called,
uh,
kicking through the ashes,
my life as a standup in the 1980s comedy boom,
which personally is my favorite,
Eric,
because I watched all of it and that was in,
that made me want to be a comedian.
And all that.
So rich,
welcome.
Welcome to the podcast bill.
Um,
I got to ask,
so what year did you start officially as a comedian?
Cause everybody always has their,
yeah,
well I did two open mics and I went to college for a semester.
People always tried it.
They always tried to delay when they stuff.
So I feel I really want me doing it six months.
They're like fucking 52.
So when is your official?
Uh,
January 77.
Wow.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
Washington,
D C there are no comedy clubs.
I was going to say like w where was their to Gig?
Yeah,
it was a,
a friend of mine,
you know,
it was funny and he said,
you're funny,
you've got to do this.
I don't even know if we knew to call it stand up cause it's gonna take you down
dude,
we can do this.
You know,
you could do it that comedy at this plan,
you were in law school and law school and a,
and a,
it was an ego on a coffee house.
It was just this basement in a church.
You know what mean?
Just all talent nights.
Right.
And I and I found a poet,
I still had the tape cause my brother didn't have the tape and the tape,
the audio,
video,
audio,
just audio,
just you know,
his big black box cassettes,
like a shoe box size cassette player recorder and uh,
and,
and the poet,
his last line was like the mango.
We are ripe for the revolution.
Oh God.
Right.
Okay.
Too late.
Huh?
Zach please.
Mango.
Nobody's talking mango in 77 but you're right way by [inaudible].
Yeah,
the Vietnam was over,
war was over.
He was still trying to do that shit.
Yeah.
So when you guys went,
that was what fascinated back then because it because of you guys that there was
a comedy club,
your whole generation is the reason why there's a comedy club scene and I've
always like read stuff about Jay Leno and it was just like,
yeah,
you need to be like,
I'd go down to the combat zone,
which was worded like the red light district,
what Boston used to be and you'd go on between like strip
anywhere,
anywhere.
This guy,
Howard Vine,
who took me at first time,
he was like my unofficial,
he says,
I found another place,
like a talent night called the gay cabaret.
And we were,
so we had,
we just thought like gay cabaret,
like the Flintstones,
this is the 77 minute closet was packed,
packed.
There was nobody out the closet except
my overpopulation pushed out.
Right.
So we could end there.
And it was,
you know,
it was a gay gay club and the guy was right.
And I said,
hey fellows,
you know,
it's normally a great soap and talent night,
but,
uh,
this was,
this is ladies night.
We don't want some months we have ladies day and again,
we're so clueless.
We don't get it.
We're like,
ladies,
like,
fantastic man.
I still don't get it.
What does that mean?
It was lesbians bottoms.
It was lesbians.
Oh,
so lesbian bottoms.
Yeah.
Ladies Nights.
So yeah.
Wow.
And I go in front of this lesbian crowd.
I mean,
they,
you know,
I'm the reason they're there to hide,
get away from guys like me.
How did it come?
Just a swing.
Oh my God.
I mean,
you know what I mean?
Chill.
I mean,
chill,
freezing cold.
I mean,
I,
woman took me off stage finally,
just,
I mean,
I got one.
I did,
I was,
like my buddy told me,
he said,
you said like,
I guess some of your worst nightmare something and got a kind of a laugh,
but you know,
you know,
student Joy,
I thought,
oh,
that's encouragement to do more instead of take that as your exit.
Yeah.
As a cue that w we,
we didn't come here for this.
Yeah,
you're done.
And the woman just walked up on stage,
took me by the arm and led me off.
Just let me up.
Just like [inaudible] I've had that,
you know,
when I started out,
I,
I had a Gig and I,
I didn't know it was a,
I didn't always the gay club,
I just got a Gig.
The fucking guy didn't tell me the place was called Queen of hearts.
And what killed me was there's only a couple of towns over from,
uh,
from where I lived.
And,
uh,
like,
yeah.
And that was like still,
it was the eighties,
early nineties.
I was still like totally like,
uh,
um,
you know,
not accepted.
There was no Billy crystal played,
but it was like the only guy played a gay character and that whole thing just
like went away.
So when I found out I was all like parenthood,
my trucks out there,
it was all like homophobic,
come over to suck a Dick,
right?
So I um,
I went there and I was wearing my college,
like sweatshirt came walking in like a 23,
24 year old and I walked by this guy and I forget what the hell he said.
He just said like,
oh my God,
my fantasy or something like that.
And I was just like,
I was like,
wow,
that was really forward.
So I went down to the end of the bar and uh,
one of the women I was working with that was like,
I walked in,
she goes,
hey bill,
how are you doing?
I said,
hey.
guys,
hey that guy down the end of the bar go,
he's a little happy.
She goes,
why?
I got a guy,
I go down the other bar,
he goes,
I go,
he's a little happy.
And she finally got,
she goes,
bill,
everybody's a little happy here.
This is a gay bar.
And then I looked around,
I was like,
Oh shit,
I was totally freaked the fuck out there.
Then you know,
by the time I get to New York,
I was just like,
I,
you know,
you start broadening horizons.
You don't give a shit.
But uh,
so you started out there.
So when I,
what made it blow up the way it did that all of a sudden there was just,
you could,
you know,
instead of having to go on after a poet or a stripper or whatever you had to do,
like I was always interested like what,
what,
like what years?
Then all of a sudden these scenes started all these independent,
like Boston had a comedy scene,
right?
The Ding Ho,
you know those guys,
those Lenny Clarke and Barry Crimmins and these,
there was a scene up there.
There was a scene in Washington DC.
We found this bar.
This guy started doing comedy at this bar.
So Louis Black,
myself,
Kevin Rooney runs them,
all of these guys showed up to start doing,
stand up as a little bar
in southeast Anacostia like there was.
And the fact that it was stand up exclusively must have been like oh yeah,
oh yeah.
It became packed immediately.
It became like wild immediate.
And there was a scene in San Francisco with the holy city zoo and that comedy
scene,
there was one in Houston and comedy workshop with Hicks and Kennison and those
guys were starting now did Elliot,
cause I know Dangerfield was around since like the 60s so like New York and La
actually,
hey had seen like I was doing it for like a year or so.
And a friend of mine said,
she goes,
you know there are comics like you doing this up in New York City.
I was like,
what?
She goes,
he had a comedy clubs.
So she took me up there and there were,
you know,
the Improv,
the comic strip and catch a rising star.
But I didn't know about until I went up there.
That's so fast and cause like there's no internet,
there's no inner knowing.
Nobody knew anything.
Like this guy comes in one night,
comes into l,
Brooklyn's like,
you know what I mean?
And he walks up to me,
he goes,
hey,
I want to do a some standup communists.
Yeah,
we at the end of the show he like put guys on,
no,
I'm a comic out in San Francisco.
We were doing like this out in San Francisco was like what?
She had got a place,
a holy city zoo.
His name was Tony de Paul and he was running a holy cities.
Let's say you tell me you're going to come out of here man,
we're doing this out there too.
And I was like,
what?
People are doing this?
You didn't think like people are doing it,
we're just doing it.
And you don't know.
Nobody was talking to,
there's a scene in Philly.
There were about six or seven cities that had scenes percolate,
percolate.
So how did those guys back in the day,
like if they had to do way back to like Ed Sullivan,
like how did you put your set together?
I know this guys did Vegas and they did casinos.
I guess you just had to be based in New York or La to get stage time to
actually,
yeah,
but those guys,
they,
but they didn't there.
There were places all over there.
You know,
the,
the nightclubs started happening right after World War One when like supper
clubs and stuff,
they started doing the speakeasies and all when,
when prohibition came in,
so the comics moved in,
out of Belleville,
started moving into these nightclubs to make real money.
Right.
So that's where it started.
So they're always,
you know,
back in the fifties and sixties they call them the toilets where he's guys would
train,
you know,
they go,
you've got to work the toilets.
A little little bar out in Jersey though.
It was a little comedy,
a little show.
You'd be part of a show,
you know,
there's a singer,
dancer.
Right,
right.
It wasn't exclusively comedy that for danger fields wasn't exclusively stand up.
You know,
they try to singers and stand ups and also they were,
yeah,
they still got the piano.
They haven't changed shit.
Oh hell no man.
No,
no.
So what year did,
so then I guess,
imagine as a supper club started to go away,
then your guys' scene then created that cdot comedy club.
That's right.
To my generation.
They weren't going out to the dinner clubs.
You don't go out and have a dinner and see a show.
Nobody was doing anymore.
That was out.
You don't get dressed up as old people stuff.
So we were in rock concert.
So then that kind of like started fading.
Right.
You know,
you're going get a little older,
you want to date,
you just can't go date,
you know,
so everybody's kind of looking for the next thing.
And it happened like some guy opens up a comedy club,
you know,
there's the three paint comedy clubs out here in the late seventies in
California.
Those Mitzi opened a place down in Pacific beach and 76 and moved over to s into
La Jolla 77 and there was a guy,
Mike Kelly opened up place.
The laugh stopped down in Newport beach.
And then Mike Lacey,
which you've been out of comedy magic.
I've done her most speech in 78 there were a first three paying like paying,
they bring Cummings in from La and pay him a couple hundred bucks.
Wow.
And then Garvin's in Washington DC opens 79 January 79 start paying comics from
New York to come down and do it.
So at this point,
you've been doing it like two years or two years.
And I became the MC there and that's why I met olders comics.
I started working with Seinfeld and Bill Maher and Overton and all that.
What time,
at what point did you,
did you start to sense like,
wow man,
like I sort of jumped into this thing that has just taken off.
Like what point did it really seem like,
like this?
Like the sky's the limit.
It was almost like a real estate boom.
Yeah.
You know,
I didn't,
you know,
it didn't,
it took me while,
I mean it sucked into it.
We weren't making money,
you know the comic Strip in Fort Lauderdale open like January or so 80 and I
remember going down there and I'm working with my first wife Caralee for Joe
Bolster and mark Schiff and Kelly Rogers.
And,
and Kelly pulls me over in a comedy Condo,
right?
That the first comedy condo.
So it's clean,
it's clean and it's gonna float.
It's gonna float inside.
We've got a boat and he goes cakes at the port.
He goes,
come here,
come here.
And he goes,
whatever this guy says you can do,
tell him you can do it.
If he asks whatever he has told me,
you can do it.
So I got a phone,
guy goes,
hey,
I just opened up this club in Ottawa,
Canada.
I need a guy who could go do two 45 minutes sets.
Can you do two separate?
45 minutes shows that,
oh yeah,
Jesus Christ.
I hang up the phone,
I go,
come on.
I've got like a half a half.
They buy everything,
they take everything I'm killing,
right?
I'm killing everything.
He says,
don't worry,
you'll do it.
Go do it.
So I go up there,
I do two a week.
Right.
You don't have,
my strategy was do all the meetings you need to because he's the same crown.
He didn't,
it was a big bar.
It was just a big board.
These comedy rooms.
At first it wasn't like they slept.
Oh we're going to be,
you know,
we're open up a new club.
We want to build this club.
They just,
there was a rock bar.
He wasn't getting a lot of business in rock bar.
I don't know where he got the idea.
Some will do comedy.
Right.
So once or twice a month he was doing comedy brought a comedian in.
So I'm going to guess what happened cause they don't really pay attention to how
long you're up there.
It's just how well you're doing.
Did you pull up short on your sets or did you do think I was counting back there
man.
I'm drinking shots.
Sometimes I'm trying to come up with dumped smoking weed between the sets,
trying to come up with new,
you know,
I'm just up there doing whatever I can do to try to,
you know what I mean?
I did all the material I could do that.
I had up front and then just ran around the room like Jerry Lewis,
you know,
like I was out of my mind.
Wow.
You know,
did you save a bit for the end to close?
I didn't have any thoughts about saving bit closer opener is like just funny and
hold them,
just hold the stage and then you pulled it off,
pulled off.
So then the week the guy goes,
he's paying me.
He goes,
this was great man.
It was like a weekend,
you know,
like three days or something.
He said,
guys on the phone wants to talk to you.
I pick up the phone.
This guy goes,
I got a,
I got a club in Montreal.
I heard you're great.
You want to come down here,
come win now.
Come on Dover.
Just come over now.
And I did the next week of Montreal and then he puts me in the phone with,
with um,
uh,
mark,
um,
uh,
from yucks president from our president from [inaudible],
same thing I want,
right.
The Breslin and Toronto.
So I went up there and I did like three weeks in a row and it came back.
I'm a headliner.
I thought I'm a headliner.
Wow.
I didn't know what it was,
but I'm like,
I was at two,
three years in.
I was,
yeah,
it was like in 1980.
So I'm like three years in,
but I was opened up for a lot of rock bands.
I,
that was it.
At that point you could quit your day job.
I didn't have a day job.
My,
my last,
yeah.
My last day job was,
About then because I was,
my last day job was working in New York City.
I was cleaning out apartments for the mob.
I didn't know that's what I was doing,
but that's what I was doing.
Cleaning them out.
What?
After all down,
down,
down.
Tax got shot for another turn.
The fucking truck.
What would you do this?
You don't remember this,
but 77 on that era.
My,
my first apartment was in a base was in rural apartment,
which she slept some walls thrown up every other building was abandoned.
Squatters everywhere.
Oh,
that's the one that's out of the East village.
Bankrupt,
right?
It's bankrupt.
Dinero in taxi era.
Exactly.
So they start selling buildings for a buck.
But you had to promise to rehab the building within a year to turn it into a
rental property.
Oh my God.
Right?
So the $10.
So I'm,
I could be set for a while,
but you had to fix them money,
right?
You had to fix them up.
So I'm having a hard time paying the rent.
So the landlord goes,
hey man,
you do carpet,
you work Nitel.
I go,
yeah,
I can do carpentry work.
He says like,
well,
we're gonna help these guys.
How much of your life has been like,
yeah,
I can do that.
They just fucking showing up and right around like Jeffrey Lewis.
So that's amazing.
So you say,
yeah,
that will show up.
I go over there.
These guys in New York guys,
they forgot in three seconds.
I can't really do carpentry,
but they,
I'm,
you know,
I'm an okay guy,
get some cigarettes and beer.
Go get some cigarettes and beer force,
you know,
go do this,
go do that,
you know,
go for it.
And for them.
Right.
So at the end of the day the guy goes,
yeah,
you can't do carpet you,
but can you clean out an apartment?
I go,
well yeah I can,
you know,
my family,
I can tell me on manual labor,
man,
that's,
that's how we stay on the planet.
Manual labor.
So I show up the next morning,
there's three young Italian guys that even though there stand outside of
building or pass around a half point,
they go,
hey,
you're ready.
But yeah,
I'm the new guy.
Yeah,
yeah.
Okay,
let's go.
We went,
we're throwing squatters out,
we're cleaning out apartments.
Oh God.
And we're throwing people out of apartments,
you know,
we're going in with flow.
We're going into the shooting galleries.
Man,
people are shooting up,
we're throwing stuff out the windows.
We're are hustling people out.
Well Shit,
five bucks an hour,
five bucks an hour under the table,
five bucks in there.
Old people out on the street and I'll break down the whole emotion of that.
You walk up to the door,
is it unlocked as it locked?
You walk up the door and I'd been in a squatter place when I first moved up
there,
so I kind of understood it,
you know?
But you see it like extension cables,
running him from building a building.
They were,
you know,
just stealing from everybody to back up with your life.
So how the fuck do you see you go up to,
you live in,
you got water building.
When I first,
how does that go down?
That was,
that was 74 when I went to New York and 74 but I had no plan and you had no
money and then you'll see an abandoned building.
You walk in,
there's other people in there yet guy,
I was escaped from New York.
People crawling up out of manholes.
People,
people,
they'd get a building,
they don't,
they put you see locks on outside of the door.
There were no locks,
like a key lock.
I would have a padlock,
you know a padlock,
right?
That's how he got in and get out.
And then he'd locked inside it,
have bolts and lock
the inside and they have electricity stealing from one building or another
building,
whatever.
They were running cables or some places had no electricity.
They would just carry,
that wasn't a fire hazard.
I love this.
Some guy that actually could be working as an electrician,
but he's deciding to live for free in this fucking building if people are
fascinating.
All right,
so now at night,
now you're on the other side.
Okay,
the fucking student has become the master.
Now you're going to throw someone out like yourself as we went on drugs.
But so what was,
what was that Po was crying,
screaming,
fighting.
No.
People were like,
okay,
cool.
Cause they'd gotten notice.
It wasn't like surprised.
They did notice it.
Put those,
this building is been bought and you've got to leave,
evacuate,
you know,
or get out whatever it is.
And they were ignoring it or they,
and so some people were cool,
okay,
we're going.
Some people that kicked in doors,
we go running and we thrown their stuff out the windows.
Right.
It was one where there's so many abandoned buildings and they'd be like,
I have,
fuck it.
I'll just grab my shit and just go down the street and around the corner.
I'll have another one.
Yeah.
I don't know what their attitude was.
I mean,
I didn't really care.
it was pretty hectic.
It was pretty.
Did you have to physically do a couple times we had to like fight off people or
push them around.
But you had some guys in the rough.
These guys were rough.
They were young and rough man.
Oh,
okay.
Did they have the Joe Pesci suits and shit?
No.
I watch too many movies.
They were trade suits.
They were dressed.
They were dressed and ready for business.
Oh,
the three quarter letters.
Plastic quote,
a leather,
but every jerk-off like Warren.
I was not that guy,
man.
Wow.
That's fucking amazing.
So,
um,
I didn't want to spend too much on your past because we're here to,
to,
uh,
I mean we're definitely going to go back because I'm a geek for all of this
shit.
But,
uh,
let's talk about the presence here.
You're kicking through the ashes.
The parts that I read,
what I loved about it is you,
you do not sugar coat any like the what happened?
The odds of you making it anything.
It was really kind of like,
like you just kind of laid it out there.
Yeah.
Like how do,
um,
I know you've done books in the past and stuff and how did this whole thing
like,
I mean it had to be through just telling stories that guys like me,
no one how interested I am in this shit.
You know,
you tell these stories for years,
you tell these stories and sometimes I hear stories come back and go,
well that's,
that's my story.
That's not how it went.
You know,
you'd tell the story or whatever.
Like the Allie Jo Prater story on hear stories and be like,
like the Comey had that one.
Cause I've always seen his now he's now full.
You guys listening,
he's a legendary comic from the comedy story,
I believe had a cowboy hat and the beard.
He was,
you're right.
He was doing the Larry the cable guy,
sort of country western comic before.
And I always read his first name is oily cause I'm,
I have like a learning disability or I'm just a moron.
And then someone finally said the name.
I'm like,
Oh shit.
That's how you say his name.
So that guy,
Gilbert Hertzog was his real name.
Gilbert Hertz.
Hartsock heartsong and he went by Ali,
Joe Prater,
Ali,
Joe printed look like your somebody Sam.
He just short guy was heavy and cowboy boots,
a cowboy hat,
you know,
he looked like a cartoon character and he was a classic.
See back when these clubs started popping,
the places were packed.
They didn't need guys to draw.
They had packed,
they wanted guys to sell alcohol.
We were liquor pimps.
You know who sold the most and Allie Joe would drink on stage and what crowd
would drink with him?
What would they pay you guys back then had started escalating fast.
I mean,
you first go out,
they go,
you know,
it's an 800 bucks a week and then they will want you back.
We want you back when these other clubs want you.
So these will pay you twice.
Twice.
I went up by about 400 bucks 20 years later when I started.
That's what I loved in New York when we almost had that strike,
it was like,
it was 50 bucks for a weekend spot for like 2030 years,
50 bucks,
50 bucks and everything else up,
all the corners were multimillionaires.
And finally we're like,
what the fuck?
And we asked for a hundred just knowing that we'd get like 75 and then
completely freaked out.
But uh,
anyways,
getting penalties on escalating fast.
But,
but,
but guys like Ali,
Joe Word,
you know,
he was a real,
he sold that.
You'd come in,
they go,
Ali,
Joe just sold like $13,000 worth of liquor last week.
And what was his style?
Was it?
So,
uh,
he was like,
you know,
they look it Larry the cable guy.
Foxworthy.
No,
he was blue.
He was little and he was,
and he was,
you know,
he would chug a beer and he'd start his act by just like chugging a beer and
going and then he belch and he go,
that's everything I learned in college.
Oh Jesus.
So he set the tone early.
I would not want to follow that guy today.
And he,
he was any,
and he would liberally took anybody's act and there's an old line and I don't
know whose line this was,
but somebody wants,
says if Ali Joe came up and bought your beer.
I mean she just did one of your jokes and Ali,
Joe shared a joint with you.
He did a couple of your jokes.
If Allie Joe laid down in the line of coke for you,
you just played Cleveland.
Yeah,
he didn't care.
And it seemed like back then like certainly through like Vaudeville,
like people just taking other people's shit.
It was always seemed to knowing,
but like,
it wasn't like the way it is now where it's just like,
it's,
it's like I don't post nine 11 like why are you being hostile?
Like I,
I remember seeing George Burns one time on 60 minutes or something and he said,
you know,
I used to do this bit,
blah,
blah.
You know,
he tells the joke,
he goes,
you know,
it's,
he goes,
yeah man,
it's not a great choke.
I don't think melody would steal it.
And like,
he threw that out there on TV and years later I was just thinking like,
oh,
he's just ribbon.
And then years later when I became a comedian,
I was just like,
wow.
Like he,
he really meant something by that.
And that guy must've been,
you know,
at least fucked with his act on some level that if he's,
that George Barnes is on 60 minutes and fucking call somebody out for,
for taking his shit.
So yeah.
But it didn't matter to him like it does now.
She did not see the Milton omen that it used to call him the thief of bed gags.
He owned it.
He like,
he was like,
I,
I didn't steal this one or I stole that one.
Or they didn't care like we did.
Right.
You know,
they did worry about stealing or acts back involved though.
They used to,
the only way to like prevent it was they would pay stage hands to protect their
act.
So if you came in and I just played there and then you came in,
you started doing my bits,
Sam backdrops near you.
Oh Shit.
Like give you a warning,
you know,
they get like a heavy warning.
But then see that air
shoots you could get away with before cell phone cameras and stuff.
You could literally deliberately drop it on the guy's head.
He dies out.
We know what happened to him.
He never showed up as fucking underneath the stage.
Wow.
It changed.
And Lenny Bruce's time.
See before that the comics were just kind of Shtick,
you know,
and so you're doing some shtick and it,
people were buying jokes and selling jokes and they were pretty interchangeable.
I'm from California,
boy,
my arm is tired.
It was just all shit like that.
It didn't matter.
So when Lenny and those guys started to make them what the comic said was
important,
it became artful and it mattered and you became tied to material.
So like what you said mattered and people wanted to believe that that was really
you,
right,
was really your opinion.
That was really your life.
Then it mattered.
Then you started taking things and it mattered.
Okay.
So when you come along,
I mean that's,
that's 25 years after Lenny Bruce.
The thing that it didn't matter with you guys was because there's no youtube,
there's none of that shit and you guys are just going up after poets and
strippers and stuff.
So once I got into this,
go up and survive,
or once I fucking got in the business,
it mattered.
It started matter.
But there were so few comics we could police the community ourselves.
That's the difference.
You know,
like a guy became a thief.
He doesn't get to work,
the clubs,
he doesn't get the work that a rooms.
It was like when I stopped,
when I started in Boston,
dude,
if you,
if you went over your time,
you went over your time and by over your time,
like you know,
we told you to do 25 minutes,
you did 28 28 like you were in the fucking dog house.
Like dude,
what the,
you did three extra minutes.
Like,
like it was such a huge thing and forget about stealing jokes [inaudible] like,
like I'm so fortunate that I started in Boston and all those Ding Ho guys like
so set the bar so high that if you are any hack,
if you any like derivative,
they'd let you go for like two,
three years.
You're okay.
You're influenced by Gavin Sweeney or Nazi or something.
But then after that it was just like,
dude,
you need to come up with your own shit.
And,
but,
and it was one of those things like Boston's an unforgiving place.
So it's just like once you will labeled,
you will,
you had to leave.
So,
um,
see that's it.
That's it.
You got trained,
you got trained,
there's nobody doing that training anymore,
but you got trained and that's how he did.
Involved.
Built to the same sort of things,
man.
They trained you,
they trained,
the guys would be coming up,
they'd have to learn to do it the right way or you wouldn't get any time.
What was the first like real comedy club like a lot like,
you know,
going up to Ottawa,
but like you,
you weren't,
you felt like,
like when did all like those a room start coming up?
Like the punchlines,
the talent started around 82.
They all started,
you know,
there's some great rooms have started.
A lot of these rooms they started at,
I mean I wrote in the book,
there's one like you go,
you went up to Minneapolis to play a room.
I'm going to play place called Mickey Fins.
Now all of these rooms rejected just to them together.
So I get out there and you know,
I felt like the gunslinger coming to town,
I'm like one of the first acts they bring in.
I'm from New York.
I see all those guys.
Jeff says Stereo Louis Anderson,
Ross standing in the back while bill bower are standing in the back.
I said that,
knew that there was a local comics there.
Guys were all from,
from Minneapolis,
Minnesota.
They're all back in the room.
They're all staying.
I see.
I can see them.
You gotta get pim,
you go there.
They are.
They're here to check me out.
Right?
So I'm going to
hit that stage,
man.
I'm,
and we'll let him know I'm here man.
I'm going to rub their man.
I'm going to rock,
you know?
Right.
So I hadn't checked anything out so I go running up and jump on the stage.
The stage was just a bunch of milk cartons,
right?
No crates with a sheet of plywood on top God.
So I go fly.
I just surfed the whole thing.
The whole thing just takes off.
I just go flying today,
blow to a couple of tables,
hit the wall partially separate my shoulder,
jump up like probably the biggest laugh.
You've got that right.
Juge they're like,
everybody's laughing at you.
They put the stage back in place and I did my set.
Oh my God.
So who else?
Now who else was a part of that Minneapolis scene?
That was a big names to say.
Oh yeah,
I understand.
Yeah.
You've been watching Lujan Zach guy.
Yeah,
he's great.
That's what I love about comedy is is this sometimes is like,
dude,
you should do something with this person,
but who would ever would have thought that we should play?
Zach's dad and Zach was,
I went to clown college in France and ends up in Bakersfield,
California.
I was talking to my wife about that last night.
We were a laying in bed and then the commercial came on for it and that just
like this fucking like perfect casting together going like who to have like
night.
That's it in the way that they,
they go back and forth.
It's like they've been working together for like 50 years.
They're like an old comedy team.
That's one of the things that one of my favorite things as like a,
cause I eat despite how long I've been in this business,
I've always just,
I've maintained that whole nerd,
sorta huge fan of,
um,
of stuff like that.
So,
um,
who is a guy that when you was in the early eighties,
like,
you know,
there's always those guys that,
when you start out,
you're just like,
there's no fucking way this person,
this person doesn't make it.
Nobody's going to make it.
Like those guys,
you could be the worst manager in a world and you knew that someone was gonna
make a,
do you remember seeing anybody like that?
Well,
you knew this is,
you know,
a lot of guys don't realize it,
but you do look it back.
You go like Leno,
Jay Leno,
first time I saw him,
I go,
this guy's a killer.
I've always heard that.
I heard.
He's like,
I mean,
just destroyed rooms.
He had the belt for like,
what?
Yeah,
15 years before he,
basically,
before he had to do the tight show every night.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
I'd go into clubs and I'd be like,
I'd go in.
First thing I'd say is,
who's got the record?
Who's got the time?
You know,
who's done the longest here?
Eh,
this Guy Colin it down and 45 it's done tonight.
It's over tonight.
You know,
I'm doing it too easy,
you know,
and I'd go gun them for everybody.
And then I'd go into town and after Leno started working at close,
right when he started doing Letterman start popping,
[inaudible] going to go.
Who's got the other that Jay Lin just at three hours,
three hours.
What did you lock the doors like Wagnerian opera.
What they do hold the audience in it at you have four ovations.
They brought him back four times and he still had the materials.
That's what's always blown my mind about those people.
Like man,
that was a period where people were trying to like set the record and they've
gone on stage for like seven,
eight,
nine hours.
I was just always picturing like eight hours in you just like,
Hey,
what's up with chairs?
You know,
just like,
like how do you still have yeah,
yeah.
At that point it's just like you're just not getting off stage.
That's,
you know,
like world.
Right.
You might as well you sitting on a fucking flagpole it,
that's not exactly excellent kills me.
Somebody actually sat there and watched all of that and there's a fucking,
you know,
two people left from the waitstaff that have to stay
there.
This was,
but this was a legit show.
This was a legit show.
Cause people were drinking and doing coke and they had,
they,
the crowd could hang right.
This will legit this for the drunk driving laws change.
This was a little different.
What class were you from as far as like,
so I know you were in New York.
How long were you in neutral?
Belzer was the king in New York stand up comedy back then?
Yeah,
he was,
I mean,
you'd seen him work that room catch.
He just owned it,
you know,
he,
he just set the record for playing like a,
a TV character for the longest time on a show or something like that.
He said something and I remember being in Nick's comedy stop and the early
nineties and he was headlining and he was going,
yeah,
you know,
they want me to do this,
uh,
this procedural show or something like that and I know what you think you can
think of actually.
Should I do it?
I remember sitting in the back club going,
what the fuck is this guy asking us?
Course you're going to do it.
Should I be on TV?
Absolutely.
I didn't realize how much money he was making as a comedian,
but like,
uh,
it's Kinda cool that I,
I remember reading that like within like the last like few weeks that he just
set some fucking record for playing the same guy in the same show since
basically my entire standup career,
like almost last 25,
25 years had been that long.
Yeah.
So you are a,
he was the guy,
Gilbert Godfrey I saw when he,
you saw him.
We were like that,
that he's the guy I want to,
I once watched him too many nights in a row and went down to the East River and
burned all my material burned on my notebooks.
Oh Geez.
Burned them all.
I said,
I'm just hack.
I've always told this story.
One of my favorite ones I ever saw him,
he went up at Nick's comedy stop one time in front of a bunch of fucking drunk
Boston morons and they were not getting him and he didn't waiver at all.
He did his shit.
He had this little old man,
yellow sweater on.
And I remember one of his jokes,
cause all the comics were dying laughing.
He was just bombing in front of this crowd.
I remember he goes,
yeah,
I went to a party the other night and I ran into Jackie Onassis and I said,
Jackie,
do you remember where you were?
And we're all dying laughing and nobody got it.
Nobody got the joke.
And then he would just go onto the next one and do fucking dead like silence.
And he toughed his way through that.
But,
uh,
first time I saw him,
I wasn't in the business was I saw him in one of the,
uh,
Beverly hills cops movies.
You weren't in Beverly Hills cop two.
What was that like?
Uh,
you know,
it's funny,
I mean,
I think I've filmed for like four days,
for five seconds of screen time.
A couple of times.
It usually works and it was fun.
It was hanging out,
you know,
it was that time when I saw it.
Wow.
This is the star Eddie,
Eddie Murphy.
There was a scene where to going,
all right Eddie,
we've got a hold on me.
And we got changed some lighting and he goes,
I'm ready.
He goes,
yeah,
but the director said,
hold on a minute and we'll get you Mitzvah.
He goes,
and he goes,
come on,
let's go.
So he goes,
grabs it like a bag of bread off the prep table,
and we'd go down to the,
the playboy mansion.
So we just go down and start feeding the geese or just telling bread to them.
So I'm about five,
10 minutes later,
one of the 80s comes into the Eddie.
They're ready for you now.
Eddie just study can turn around.
Just keep seating at the feeding them the geese.
Eddie,
we're ready.
We're ready.
He does ignore them.
They leave.
They come back five minutes later.
Eddie.
Well,
you ready now?
And he says he made them wait.
They made him wait.
He made them wait.
Oh Shit.
That's,
I go,
that's power.
That's,
you know,
he's like the fucking balls.
That guy would never,
I would never,
I'd be like,
ready?
No.
Go home schooling.
How high jump.
Yeah.
Hat in hand.
I'll never get a no,
I've never understood like people that uh,
what's,
what's funny and tragic is watching people pulling those moves when they don't
have the power,
which,
which I,
I've seen a lot,
especially now where so many aspects of the entertainment bill business because
of the Internet have just gone down this shit like the entire music business.
You know,
anybody nowadays who complains when be it all the good music girl sucks.
I always go,
well,
you get what you pay for.
I'm guilty of it too.
I,
I stole pipe Lyme wired a lot of shit.
I lie.
Yeah.
A couple of fucking laptops that just got virus out before somebody finally went
like,
dude,
you're in this business,
you should pay for it.
Like I think it might've been Russman,
eve in New York said that to me and I haven't,
I haven't illegally downloaded a song or anything and like let a thousand years
way back to like a Napster limewire was the last one that I use.
So,
um,
but anyways,
yeah,
I've seen people like,
um,
try to pull that too.
You know who I am and all of that.
And in the people who do that now it's just like,
dude,
you're not paying attention to this business where like remember like back in
the day to try to get,
if they got like two major stars in a movie,
it was just like,
holy fuck,
this is going to be like a blockbuster.
Forget about now where like every movie is like Ocean's 11 I'm like,
I got like,
like everybody got just bumped down.
Like,
like,
like the shit that I would go in and audition for in like the nineties you'll
have now a guy who like used to star in fucking movies,
like B level movies is going and taking that spot.
All these stars are on TV and you just see these people pulling them moves.
But um,
that I,
I can't,
I mean that happens on a movie set.
Like,
like the lighting isn't right.
It's a lot of waiting around.
I mean there,
there's an entire crew film crew there,
people all over.
They had,
you know,
the scene was they were going to shoot Eddie just walking past a bunch of women
playing volleyball in Bikini's.
Right,
right.
So we get up to the scene and they start doing it and the director's yelling,
he goes,
jump higher,
girls jump higher,
jump higher.
He's trying to get jiggled going.
And I see,
I go to Eddie Ego,
there's too much dupont out there,
man and Eddie,
cause I love you don't have Draeger's what?
Then he goes,
he tells me what he said,
director lady goes,
yeah,
you're right.
All right,
let's shoot the scene and forget it.
Oh,
it's all silicon man.
Ain't no jiggling happen.
Now.
How was Eddie handling a,
I mean,
did you know Eddie before?
Yeah.
Knowing from back in New York in the day.
I mean the first time he came in the,
in Provos I was the MC on Sunday night.
I was like the regular when I was in town,
I wasn't,
when I was down like 46 or 45th street on the west side.
It was on 44th 44th and ninth.
Right.
Right there.
Yeah.
Cause I used to live in that neighborhood and we used to go down and uh,
I read this whole thing.
It might've been something I heard from you or something and it's almost like
it's a pizza place or something.
And that's where prior that really robbed video of him just standing when he was
stopped being the bill Cosby clone and he was turned into Richard.
Like he literally was turning in to Richard Pryor the greatest of all time.
And like that always blew my mind that that was within like 15 blocks of where I
lived.
And I would go in there and get the pizza.
The pizza was only okay,
but I just wanted to be like set like see that wall.
Well just wondering where the fucking stage was.
Yeah.
Can I ask a total key question when you walked into that,
because it's basically the same space,
right?
Where was the stage walk in
the stage is all in the back of the room.
There was a,
there was an emergency door exit right by the stage and the stage is a little,
you know,
was it all one room?
There was no walls.
He didn't want them.
There's one room,
there was a bar,
there's a,
there's a bar out there.
Everybody hung out in the bar.
It was a good bar,
cool bar.
Everybody hung out there and then you'd walk through this little narrow noodle,
narrow hallway but short,
you know,
and the men's bathroom was on the right hand side of literally like a toilet and
a in a sink in,
in like a windows little closets.
And then you'd walk in this little hall and the light was right there.
It's like by the service bar.
So if you're on stage and you see Rodney come under that light,
you know,
you go danger fields here,
it got to get off,
got to get into riding on quick.
He's making the rounds,
getting ready to do a tonight show or something.
So you'd see people pop up into that light area,
probably see his fucking silhouette too.
And you know who he was?
Oh yeah.
You just see him.
You just see me.
Just he pop any man.
As soon as you saw him,
he pop out and you know,
get up.
And Rodney,
I was like,
because I saw Rodney and I was on the stage.
I'd cut mid joke,
you know,
and then that,
hey,
we've got a special guest here.
And right away I remember going off and Rodney coming on and goes,
hey,
you know how to fucking move the kid though has moved,
man.
He moves.
He goes on a move.
That's awesome man.
You know,
like that,
it just reminded me one time I did a,
uh,
I did a benefit at this,
um,
theater in beacon,
beacon theater.
I forgot what the hell the goddamned benefit was.
What was the sickest lineup I was ever on.
It was a,
John Stewart was hosting,
Max Weinberg brought his band.
Tony Bennett goes on first,
then Bruce Springsteen,
then the auctioned off one of his guitars to this rich crowd that goes for like
a hundred grand.
Then fucking Joe Mchale had to follow that.
Like I,
Joe McHale's got,
he has to have the,
I followed fucking story.
Right.
Um,
and then I went up after him,
which,
you know,
he was the total buffer to get it back to,
all right.
Settle down here.
Right.
Your expectations.
This is what you paid for you.
Right.
And Seinfeld was closing.
That was the lineup.
And um,
I remember when I was doing my set,
I was conscious about not being too dirty cause I mean Seinfeld's like the king.
And I remember looking over,
I was getting close to the end of my set and he was standing on the side of the,
uh,
the stage and you know,
the light was behind him.
So he was like back lit.
And I,
I knew who he was with his silhouette.
Like that's how famous this guy is.
And to me,
and it wasn't just Jerry hanging out,
he had the suit on,
it was Jerry ready to go to work.
And I was immediately thinking like,
oh my God,
am I too blue?
Is he going to hate me?
Am I pissing him off?
Am I going over [inaudible]?
And I remember when I got off stage,
he went like a,
I walked by him and I was just,
and I was just,
I was almost afraid to say hello.
I just like walked by and east went very funny,
very funny.
And then I apologize for working,
you know the way I do.
I said,
oh sorry,
blah blah blah.
And he goes,
I don't care.
You almost like laugh.
Like dude,
I don't give a shit.
And I'm thinking like,
that's right.
This guy always worked clean and he worked cleaned before there was even comedy
clubs.
So I can't imagine him going on after these guys who would chug a beer and then
burp and be like,
that's what I learned in college.
And like that's sorta energy is fun,
but it whips them into like this Fred Frat boy frenzy.
And then you gotta go up there and if you have like a more of a,
you know,
just straight lace kinda like,
yeah,
I mean I have a beer every once in a while,
but guys,
like I'm not letting this totally affect my life,
you know.
Well first of all,
I love the fact that you did that.
That's the training.
Got in Boston and go,
I'm part of this show.
I know I'm not closing,
so I'm going to respect the headliner.
Oh yeah.
How it works here.
Oh,
that was another,
that was another way that you would get,
you would get blackballed.
I remember,
uh,
there was a comedian up there,
Mike Donovan,
you ever work with them?
I know who he is.
Fucking hilarious guy.
And he used to always say this thing was hilarious and it'd be like,
it'd be like,
yeah,
just go up there,
uh,
you know,
do like 20 minutes,
keep it like,
you know,
three to five fucks is,
what are you saying?
It is a thing.
He wasn't bullshitting.
He was just like,
people in Boston counted the fucks.
So I remember,
uh,
you know,
sometimes going over it and being in a panic,
like,
oh my God,
that was my sixth fuck Donovan's going to call my Clark and I'm going to be,
I'm going to be ruined in this town.
I said fuck six times.
So,
um,
I mean,
I don't want to sit there and be like the old guys and just cause I don't know
what it is like for kids coming up now and mindset kids to me now or anyone up
to like 32,
33,
um,
coming up now.
But I'm sure that they have their,
uh,
their whole way that,
that they don't always change it.
But I like that.
But you know,
Seipel always had that discipline.
I remember working with him again,
these Jersey gigs,
so he's,
Jersey gigs were like $55 Jersey.
This started,
there was like the first paying gigs we could get,
go out to Jersey and some bar.
Right.
And so,
you know,
it's survival time in a bar.
So a lot of guys would be like,
what do I gotta do to get by,
you know,
fuck with a garage,
shit,
Dick Jokes,
whatever I gotta do to get by.
Right.
And I remember working with Jerry on time and he goes on and he'd follow all of
that and he stays right to what he's doing.
Man Works Clean.
Brings him to him.
No,
but he wasn't killing it.
It's not like all,
they all came to him.
They were like,
oh wait,
the parties over it,
it wasn't great,
but he never broke.
He never wavered.
And afterwards I'd go,
wow man.
He goes,
he goes,
I'm getting ready to do it tonight.
Shows that's what I'm preparing to do.
He had the folks who had the long reach focus.
He was like,
I'm practicing this material here now because I'm going to do this on the
tonight show.
I'm working this out now.
I'm not worried about my $55 Jersey Gates.
Well,
he's one of those guys,
long range view.
He's one of those guys that he just fucking knew where you I've,
yes,
he,
I knew
where he was going and he just,
uh,
you'll never meet a guy that doesn't suffer fools the way he does.
I still want to get around.
Am I getting nervous?
I'm like,
I'm going to say one stupid thing and this guy is going gonna I'm going to get
that look.
And that's just going to be,
you'll try the long,
the same way.
Like his act is the way he lives his life.
There's no fat,
there's no extra words or any of that type of shit.
And then the guy just fucking,
just like,
he just walks towards what he wants,
walks right through it.
I mean,
not,
not like in a malicious way.
Just like he just,
I on the fucking prize.
That guy,
you don't go back in the day guys,
we're going like,
you know,
and I'm like,
is that cause you don't really know who he is up there go.
Are you fucking paying attention?
Yeah.
You know?
Exactly.
You know what pissed this guy off the missing sock in a fucking dryer.
That's who he is,
man.
I just paid attention.
He's fucking paying attention to the details.
That's what's irritating.
This guy,
I did his web series one time and I told them that.
I told them I hated that.
They said his show is a show about nothing.
It's like,
no it isn't.
This guy has contempt for 90% of people and activities.
I was actually nervous saying it to him and he laughed and he goes,
I think you're being generous by saying you know that it's only 90% percent.
Yeah.
Um,
that's so fucking cool.
So when did like,
uh,
Oh God,
there's so many things I want to ask you this as far as,
so the Improv,
the Improv started in New York City and then they opened the La one,
right?
Cause they opened the la one because he realized everything was moving out to
la.
When Johnny moved with Carson,
moved,
that was when he moved to the 72.
The whole thing shifted.
The axis shifted,
right?
Everybody had to go out to La and the comedy stores just opened them.
So La comedy store became people going on on the tonight show going,
yeah,
I work out the comedy store in La.
That became the place.
Wow.
Right.
So buddy's like I got to get out there.
Yeah.
And then the cause he wasn't getting the brand recognition and no,
he was getting the,
when he was in New York and the comics go on the tonight show in New York and
go,
I've worked out the Improv here in New York,
like Klein or those comics.
But then it shifted immediately it,
that's why Leno went right out to La la,
no salt,
Freddie Prinze go on the tonight show and say,
I'm working at the comedy store and Linda Goes,
I've got to get out to the economy store.
Yeah.
Right.
And so the franchise didn't start opening until the eighties like 84 when Mark
Anderson opened one in San Diego.
Then that started,
he started opening up this franchise.
Did Bud like bud franchise out franchise that when he saw the whole boom happen,
that's when he made money.
That's when he really made money.
Mark Anderson opened his clubs and bud was making you,
it's like the Trump thing.
Well I've heard a lot of that stuff that says Trump on it.
They're,
they're paying for the name for the name.
That's so,
so bud was getting like a gross of every club.
I think I gotta ask him,
cause like I,
you know,
you're doing the tonight show with Johnny Carson,
which has to be the most nerve wracking.
Huge possible thing.
Like sleepless nights and like,
yeah.
What year did you,
did you first do 84 you didn't [inaudible] 85 oh my God.
So you're going to go on there.
I mean it's just at that point it's that show like I feel bad for young people.
They don't understand how huge that fucking show was.
It was just like,
it was,
it was everything.
Everybody's was the Beatles on Ed Sullivan.
It was comic,
it was everything.
It was everything.
So you,
they tell you,
you're getting the show.
So you must be like over the moon,
excited.
And then for me,
what were immediately hit would be the dread of like,
I'll fuck now,
I have to do this and I have to somehow compartmentalize the fucking terror of
this guy who can either invite me over,
give me the okay.
Or all of my peers are going to see that he didn't like me cause I watch that
shit.
So everybody watched it.
Yeah.
So here's the deal,
how it worked,
and correct me if I'm wrong here,
he would give you,
what would he give you?
The,
okay.
He didn't call you.
You need to call you over.
That was the highest.
That's it all you got the,
okay,
so you still coming back,
right,
which is accepted for the first time.
You'll know.
But then there was the one where he would just be like [inaudible] drumming his
pencil on the table and take his pencil and just drumming it and not looking at
you.
And that was like it.
Man.
That was the worst.
Uh,
and he knew he was,
he knew what he was doing to the comment.
Cut that down.
I read it.
I read that book that his lawyer read.
I mean it was great book.
How ice cold his mother was like the ability to do that.
It's like that's the trickle down effect.
Um,
I'll tell you how I dealt with doing Letterman because Letterman was my Carson.
Like I literally had to,
I was so fucking like thinking,
what am I gonna do?
I had to like work up like a healthy level of hatred cause that's just how I'm
wired.
I'd be like,
yeah,
fuck this guy for making me so fucking that name.
He was a great guy,
came over,
shook my hand and everything.
But like I had to literally be thinking,
fuck this guy and then to go out there.
So I went out there and I had,
thank God I had a great set and I remember like you see it on TV and you think
he's fucking 80 yards this way and the band's a hundred yards.
They're all right there.
Like you could take two steps over and shake Paul's hand.
Another three.
You could shake days.
And I remember doing my set,
hearing Dave laugh.
And it was such a fucking,
it was more of a relief.
It's like,
oh my God,
he's laughing and he's laughing.
And I was,
you know,
[inaudible] getting married.
So it was like in the wheelhouse cause he wasn't married or anything like that
as it was.
I don't know.
I just remember thinking like,
I was so fucking relieved when it was over matter.
I was just so relieved.
So tell me what that was it,
but sort of a Letterman show,
Letterman was always behind you on camera.
So the orange could,
you were,
they were letting me,
it was in the sight line.
So they're looking at you and seeing Letterman over your shoulder.
So if you'd have Letterman laughing,
you could die.
Oh Wow.
You know,
so by the time I did,
and they didn't have,
like,
he was already over at cvs says,
I'm talking bout the NBC show.
Okay.
So anyway,
84 I was in New York of,
because,
uh,
I left the summer Olympics,
we're out here and I said,
I'm going to get out of La.
There's going to be a mess.
And so Kennison and I booked over to New York for the summer and I was there and
I was working out and Jim McCauley,
the tonight show,
booker saw me in New York and said and said,
your ready man want to do it in two weeks.
It was all funny.
I like to,
so you know what,
as you cobble this block,
people don't understand.
It's
a very unnatural set back then.
I don't know how to do it then maybe they just pull five minutes out of the rack
in tack on five.
But you pull like a greatest hits thing.
You pull a joke from this bit,
you pull the two hours and you cobbled together with these weird segues.
Right.
You know you do a skiing,
water skiing joke than you and you know when you come out on water,
your hair's messed up.
You know what,
I get my haircut and then was like
torture speaking hair.
Oh,
it's horrible.
Yeah.
And so I put this set together,
you know,
that he helped me with and then I'm practicing it every night.
You know,
just going into clubs every night.
Then many times I could run out to Jersey Gig,
coming back,
doing a bunch of monitoring while you're brushing your teeth,
the whole fucking thing.
Completely freaking out.
And I,
I,
I was drinking and doing a lot of blow back then.
So I was like,
I've got to quit.
So a week before I thought this,
I'm not going to drink and do drugs.
But you high when they told you you got the Gig?
Oh yeah.
We went out to a bar afterwards.
Macaulay and I went up to a bar when he said,
you got it.
Let's go talk about it.
We went out to a bar drinking.
I didn't do blown in front of him cause I didn't know whether he did it or not.
I wasn't gonna risk that,
you know,
but we were drinking.
Yeah.
Hell yeah.
And uh,
I got so stressed out,
I got shingles,
I broke out in shingles.
Oh my God.
You know,
buy my,
my ass and my leg would just blistered up and I didn't know what that was.
I went to the doctor said you got shingles,
man,
and all that.
Yeah,
you got shingles.
That's an old man's thing.
What are you,
what are you stressed out about?
Some,
yeah.
Let me see.
I'm doing the tonight shit.
Yeah.
Then he's probably like,
wait,
when is it?
Yeah,
answer the stress.
Cause now I know you're watching it.
You're going to be at home going like,
and it's funny,
I got shingles.
He's got blisters on his ass.
Wow.
Yeah.
And so you're standing backstage,
right?
This is Burbank,
obviously 80 before the shooting of Burbank.
So the fucking curtain was iconic.
That fucking golden blue and weird ass.
All those weird colors.
All I could think about was fucking up.
I mean,
literally,
I'm like going,
I can't fuck up.
You're not thinking about how much fun you're going to have.
I didn't think like,
Oh,
I'm gonna put this coming fun man.
I earned this.
I deserve this.
I'm going to go out and go in and have a good time and say,
what's up Johnny?
You're not just like,
yeah,
yeah.
Did you have the panic thought of what if I,
what if I forget where I am?
What if I forget what I'm saying?
Cause I then had it,
didn't that happen to somebody say happened to me all my HBO special,
I blanked on my HBO special.
Oh God.
For how long?
When I had to stop taping I just went,
I'm lost,
I'm lost.
Because it was getting,
it was now instead of a five minutes unnatural,
I cobbled together a half hour out of like hours of material and posted that,
you know,
like just all together.
Just kind of just cut and paste,
cut and paste.
And I was practicing that for a long time and I got out there and I just went,
what am I doing?
What's the,
you know,
it's like one of those things where you going,
what the fuck am I doing?
Is almost like diff from death of a salesman.
What am I,
what is contentious bid here?
What happens is you go out there and rather than just doing a show,
you know you're being watched and then you start watching yourself and then you
leave yourself.
And then you're sitting in the crowd going,
why is he moving his arm like that?
Cause you're literally thinking,
oh,
I'll do it.
We've all fucking bet.
Yeah.
So when you're standing behind that curtain and you just,
it just adrenaline was unbelievable.
It was unbelievable.
Then you walk out and then you hit it.
And as soon as it,
but it's like every other time,
I mean my literally my mind went blank like every time before I go on stage,
my mind goes blank.
If you go,
what?
Jokingly the what joke?
I don't have any jokes.
I can't remember anything.
Yeah,
totally blank.
Right.
It walk out there to that first joke,
get the first laugh and go,
yeah,
you're locked in that first laugh and you're locked in.
So you went out,
you did your first joke.
Yeah.
How did it do?
Good laugh.
Got a good laugh.
And you know when you're doing it,
you're playing it.
Everybody says,
the first joke is just I'm seeing you and hearing you for the first time.
So don't expect that big laugh so you don't put your,
you know,
you know I always was told that the three jokes in,
that's your first killer joke,
right?
You know,
three jokes in.
That should be your first killer joke.
That's how you kind of planned it.
I know they all right fucking guys write their ideas and then the fifth joke
should be this.
Then you'd sell more shit to think about.
It is so natural.
It's so,
it was unnatural.
You go out there and you end up,
you end up having had this,
I would really good set.
Have a really good set set.
You'll now you're like,
how long did it feel to look over at Johnny?
Like fuck,
oh,
I'm going to lock eyes with this guy that looked over big smile,
you know,
big smile and a circle finger like you said,
like big.
Okay.
And I go,
oh,
can I came back stage?
And Jim McCauley greets me.
Got a beer,
hands be a beer.
Great.
Fantastic man to stand over here.
Stand over here.
The end to show you stand here.
And when Carson walks back,
the way he walks back a re after we show this route,
he takes backstage,
you're going right there on the route.
He stops,
shakes your hand.
That was great.
Get a photo op,
fantastic.
Come back soon.
You can come back.
So yeah,
got a picture.
You know you got a picture and you're to stand there going.
Okay.
And then he is fantastic.
He moves on right?
And you're like,
this is it.
And then you go back into the Improv that night in on Melrose,
in West,
you know West Hollywood,
right?
Everybody was there.
They turn the TV up,
everybody in a bar standing there,
you're standing there.
It kills me about how they redid that.
Now they got the bar upstairs.
It's like all,
all that history,
you guys,
all those people had stood there watching that friends to height show sex.
Everybody who leaned on that fucking bar kills me.
At least they didn't end demolish.
And John,
Johnny used to say the same thing when a new comic,
I'm glad you're in a good mood tonight because we've got a new comic coming on,
right?
And the comics would mouth it and,
and some would actually say it out loud with Johnny.
That's how much everybody knew that.
Wow.
That,
that,
that routine.
Right,
right.
And you stand there and it's like,
yeah.
Everybody saw how much bloated you do that night when you to fucking pass that
Jesus Christ.
I had coke in my pocket when I walked out onto the set that day.
That's how much I knew.
I was like,
when you watch run like fucking Ron Burgundy and all those fucking movies that I
look more like a documentary to you than rather than a comedy.
It's like,
yeah,
we did all that.
I had a suit like that.
I wore that on the tonight show.
I had blow in my pocket.
Yeah.
Wow.
Man.
That's fucking amazing.
Well,
we gotta uh,
I gotta run back to this thumb in the middle of editing this fucking cartoon
that's never going to end.
Dude.
I gotta tell man like this.
You've been one.
I've had great guests,
but this was just so fucking,
I will tell you listening,
I had as much fun as I did.
Like,
I could ask you a Zillion,
how do you not talk to a guy who fucking had coke in his pocket when he does the
fucking tonight show?
You're like,
I'm doing this either way.
This is either going to make me super happy or make me want to fucking kill
myself.
So his book is called kicking through the ashes.
My life is to stand up in the 1980s comedy.
Boom.
I'm,
where can people get this?
amazon.com amazon.com will do book soup,
uh,
assigning a book signing at book soup over in West Hollywood on January six,
January six,
seven o'clock,
January six.
I'm going to do a sunny and tell some stories.
Will you have any coke in your pocket?
I'll have a slow seal.
Fill with sugar.
That's rich.
It's been such a pleasure,
man.
Thank you so much for calling.
I'll say this.
My son's angry.
He can't beat it yet.
He's a huge fan.
Oh Geez.
He huge.
That's awesome.
He is 17 years old.
He is a banger man and he's so digs you.
And he was like,
Oh dad,
man,
can I get out of school?
Can I just Nah,
can't do it.
He's of age and can come out to the clubs.
Three shout or now,
hopefully.
I'm still funny at that point.
All right guys.
Rich shine everybody.
Thank you so much for coming on man.
All right man.
Alright.
Is a little bit of advertising for your over there.
Um,
all right.
Loot crate.
Give it a loo.
Be The envy of your friends and get your 100% exclusive
crate@lukecraig.com slash burr and enter my code name Burr to save $3 off,
um,
on any new subscription.
Wait until I tell you about December's crate.
It will have you fight in the power man.
Luke crate offers an epic range of pop culture items for less than 20 bucks a
month.
If you're more of a fanatical Fashionista than try loot where monthly wearables
and accessories with cult classics and your favorite franchise.
If you want to get fancy and get a bigger box,
the with even bigger loot,
there's loot crate dx.
Want to geek out your pet.
Try loot pets.
They got everything.
They got all of that shit.
Get ready for December's rebellious theme.
Revolution A,
they've designed a system to keep you down,
man and their meddlesome.
Hello friends.
It's time for a revolution.
December.
December's crepe features exclusive items from assassin's creed.
Mr. Robot Firefly,
our monthly t-shirt and pin and more including exclusive Funko.
Pop Your Dad's garage band Funko pop.
Do not wait.
You have until the 19th at 9:00 PM Pacific to subscribe for December's crate.
When it's over,
it's over.
I'm no more a noma crates.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burn into my code bur bur to save $3 off on any
new subscription today.
All right,
Lyft,
everyone you'd know about Lyft,
right?
It's the app.
It gets you ride minutes on demand 24,
seven for less than the cost of a cab.
Uh,
if you tried Lyft,
um,
you know what I mean?
What with lifts,
you just download the app request to driver and they show up in three and a half
minutes on average.
That's really fast,
man.
Every Lyft drivers fully vetted through the 10 point safety standard,
including criminal d of the background checks.
You know,
you'll get around quickly and safely.
Lyft drivers are rated after every dried,
so only the best stick around.
You don't have to worry about getting into a filthy car with some creepy dude.
With Lyft,
you can tip in the app,
which is obviously leads to a happier drivers.
I mean,
nine out of 10 live riders rides get a perfect 5% rate from their passenger.
It's just a better all around experience.
Bigger isn't always better.
Lyft isn't the biggest ride sharing app,
but it's the fastest growing and highest rated one.
I'm talking quality over quantity.
Thanks to Lyft,
you got an easy way to avoid drunk driving.
You never have to bum a ride and you never have to worry about parking.
A lot of people are actually getting rid of their cars.
Isn't that true in relying on Lyft to get around down there?
Just talking shit here and you know what?
I don't ever deadly.
I don't blame them.
According to the coffee right now,
Lyft is offering listeners a special deal.
Get three rides up to $10 each.
That's a,
that's a $30 value.
If you can't do basic math when you enter the Promo code bill bird,
just download the free Lyft app today and enter the Promo code bill burden.
The payment section.
You'll start with three free rides,
up to $10 each.
That's a $30 value.
That's Promo Code Bill Bar.
Enter Promo Code Bill Burr.
Alright.
SeatGeek everybody.
Oh,
the geeks with the seats.
Buying tickets online for sports and concerts has been a confusing process for a
long time.
Yeah,
you get ripped off.
It's not confusing.
There's no confusion there.
It's like,
why the fuck does this cost so much?
Am I this far away from the God damn action?
It's always been hard to find the best deal for the game that you want or the
show you want to go to and none of that.
None of these older tickets sites want to change that,
but seat geek is different.
They've come along with an created an amazing app and website that makes it
easier than ever for fans to buy and sell tickets.
Everything about seeks is designed to make life easier for sports and music
fans.
Siki does all the price comparisons for you by searching multiple tickets sites
and ensuring that you get the best possible deal.
Seek does all the work and you save time and money.
Best of all,
my listeners get $20 zero $20 rebate off their first SeatGeek purchase.
To get your $20 rebate on tickets,
I'm download the SeatGeek app.
Go to the settings tab,
oh Jesus and click add a promo code.
Enter Promo Code [inaudible] seek equal send you a $20 $20 after you've made
your first ticket purchase,
download the SeatGeek app and enter the Promo Code Berth today.
Be One of these fucking reads is over a minute.
Let's try to blow through this one here.
All right.
Simply safe.
Ever find yourself almost all the way to work or maybe you were out with family
and friends and you get that Nag and feeling that I closed that door.
Why am I married to this person?
Did I lock that door?
You just don't have to.
You just don't know if you drive yourself nuts thinking about that shit.
Well you don't have to worry about that shit anymore cause you got simply safe
home security.
It's a nice extra layer of protection to know.
Simply safe is there.
Simply safe has an arsenal of sensors to protect your entire home and keep your
family safe.
Uh,
simply safe.
They just keep saying the fucking name here.
Got Rid of everything that makes most home security.
Such a pain.
There's no longterm contracts,
no hidden fees.
They won't gouge you.
It's just 1499 a month.
That's three times less than what other companies charge.
And you're some big news.
Simply safe.
Just released this brand new high definition security cameras.
This camera is different.
It connects to your security system and sends your smart phone a video.
The second something happens,
hey look at that asshole fucking breaking into my house,
jerking off of my couch.
You can see everything that's going on is you're eating your fucking souffle so
you won't have to wonder anymore.
Oh,
that's why my house is going to be trashed when I get home.
Check out simply safes.
New Camera today.
Just go to simply safe bird.com right now.
That's simply safe bird.com hey,
simply safe bird.com
I was riding on the Mayflower when a photo spots and the land.
I am for captain a rep a have you on the stand who came running to the deck?
Zed Boys.
Forget the whale.
What?
Going on?
Young Kathy and engines changed to see how on the bowline noise sang then
Melodie tough sailors do and the fire with Red Sea.
Yeah.
Have yourself a merry little Christmas
led.
The you tied glow.
I don't know though was bad.
I'm gonna keep going.
Here we are playing patty cake with some mistletoe and a
[inaudible].
Santa Claus has in itchy beard and big black boots sit in his lab.
I don't know why.
I can't say merry Christmas.
Somewhere along the line it became offensive even though I don't mean anything
bad by a
lot of,
some Mexican came up to you and said,
happy Cinco de my.
Yo,
what'd you say?
Dude?
What the fucking fuck.
It's all just April to me.
[inaudible]
friends.
It's that time of year again.
Oh
boom.
When the fuck did you know,
say a merry Christmas,
become offensive,
Bah,
blah,
blah by Buddha.
You know,
I don't understand that shit.
Just cause they say it that,
you know,
I,
it's like if somebody Jewish said Happy Hanukkah to me,
uh,
you know,
I wouldn't be like,
what the fuck dude,
blah blah,
blah,
blah.
You know,
what the fuck?
I don't understand that.
I like seeing my Christmas makes me feel good,
makes me feel good right in my chest.
Feel a little warm feeling just like the Grinch,
you know,
when his little heart kind of broke out of that little box.
Doo,
Doo Doo,
Doo Doo.
This is a little holiday break down is a,
as I,
as I kick knowledge about the holidays,
um,
whatever.
So have yourselves,
and maybe a little Christmas he is,
I don't hate Muslims or Jews when I say merry Christmas.
So whatever group he's walking around saying it's offensive,
go fuck yourself.
Then you're fucking con.
Even if you're male,
you have a con because you've ruined part of my holiday.
I would never do that to you.
All right,
that's enough.
Jesus Christ.
Sorry.
You know.
Anyways,
how are you?
I know I'm tone deaf,
but you know,
I told you I was going to embrace the holidays and shit when I was at the
airport coming back from a Vancouver listen to this week that I had,
first of all,
this is the Monday morning podcast.
Usually if I'm going to sing badly,
I only do it for a couple of seconds,
but,
uh,
you know,
I don't know.
I just so I can,
I of felt it,
um,
and I was just in Canada and they say merry Christmas up there,
which makes me feel good because you know what?
That's what I say,
you know,
do I have to go to Canada now?
They listen to somebody say merry Christmas.
I don't know.
What if the fuck are these?
How big are these groups?
I think you just need like literally 18 people and they just,
you know,
they just hold up signs and they talk,
Oh,
what up?
Fuck Nah,
fuck.
And the way they frame it on the news,
they make it look like it's a zillion people.
You know,
I,
you know,
I don't know.
It's weird.
I'm trying to think of whatever said Merry Christmas to the two.
A friend of mine who's Jewish and he ever got offended.
I don't think they ever did
so well.
So what?
18 Una teeny of friends get offended by this shit.
And then you get to call yourselves a group and then you get to start walking
around telling people what's offensive and what isn't.
These are the holidays you can,
once you fucking open your hearts to another religion.
All right?
So anyways,
this is,
um,
listen to this fucking week that I had.
All right,
you want to talk about busy cause my brain is going to be all over the place.
I'm already telling you that.
All right?
And I might even sing another holiday fucking song if I feel like I'm eight
though.
Nobody's saying he can.
You know,
I don't understand the hostility.
Why don't you relax?
Okay.
You just got back from the airport.
You haven't showered yet.
You know,
you should have taken a little bit of time,
showered,
you know,
treated yourself and gotten yourself in a mindset where you can relax a little
more and do a happier podcast.
But you didn't,
you ordered a grilled cheese sandwich and some chicken noodle soup and you
fucking went right in wearing the clothes that you've been sitting in since last
night at the Canuck game and now you're laying on your bed.
That's disgusting.
Um,
anyways,
this is my week.
See what I did.
I just talked myself down thought more calmer tone.
I like this.
This is the new me.
This isn't the new me.
This is the guy I'm trying to be.
This is the person I think I was before.
A bunch of fucked up shit happened to me and became me.
This make me become like the screaming maniac than I am.
So I'm trying to get back in touch to me circuit in 1972,
um,
anyways,
this is my week.
Monday
I saw,
uh,
I flew back from New York City after a wonderful engagement at Caroline's comedy
club.
And,
uh,
I landed,
I had a sandwich and then me and three of my friends all went down to the La
Forum.
We saw ACDC that was Monday,
you know,
most people would call it a fucking week right there and be like,
wow,
I just saw one of the most legendary rock bands of all time.
Brian Johnson's voice sounded unbelievable.
He looked like he was having the time of his life.
Angus was still jumping around and I'm sick of people on this tour going,
you,
you know,
Anglesey you know,
he's great,
but you know,
he kind of admit,
you know,
he kind of,
he's kind of lost a step.
It's like,
dude,
so have you,
I don't understand how people feel like,
you know,
they look at famous people like they're not supposed to age,
and you know,
if,
if people fucking videotaped you taken out your trash seven years ago,
the last time ACDC was on tour,
I bet you don't have such a big spring and y'all fucking step either.
Stop making fun of Angus,
the guys jumping around.
It's 53 years of age.
Never missing a note.
Try doing that at 16.
Tried doing the shit that he does.
I dare you to try that on you.
Fucking a you a little playstation game,
Guitar Hero.
You think you could do that for an hour and a half and then do a strip cheese
and moon the crowd and then come right back in.
Jump up a fucking drum riser and be right on the fucking one.
I don't think you could do that.
Leaving us alone.
They were the shit.
That was my Monday.
Right?
And then,
um,
Tuesday I began three straight,
12 hour days shooting my pilot for comedy central,
which could not have gone better.
I think.
Uh,
we got a lot of fucking hilarious stuff.
Um,
I made a very smart move.
I pulled the Seinfeld,
I learned a lot from Jerry Seinfeld.
You know,
he uh,
you know,
what did he do?
One time I watched him like and accept that accept an Emmy for his show and he
said something to the effect of,
Hi,
I'm Jerry Seinfeld and I am a bad actor but I've proven if you surround yourself
with enough talent,
youtube and,
but Davita did it,
whatever.
So I went out and tried to find the funniest fucking people I could.
So hopefully if I suck,
the people around me are okay.
So that was my Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday we wrapped at about 9:00 PM Thursday,
smoked a fucking stokey as men do.
And then I got my little Prius reeking of Dutch masters and a went home and the
next day I bought it a fucking Air Canada flight to Calgary
and proceeded Friday,
Saturday,
Sunday I went to a Calgary flame game,
then an Edmonton Euler game and then a Vancouver Canuck game.
I always wanted to go up there and uh,
I got to tell you,
it was pretty fucking amazing and pretty God damn cold.
Do you remember that shit when you were a kid?
Wherever the hell you live.
Like,
I might not,
my nose has not stuck together when inhaling since I went collecting on my paper
route and like the fifth grade,
um,
Calgary,
I don't know what the fuck is in Calgary.
Okay,
let me do my little review of the western part of Canada.
All right.
Calgary first stop.
Um,
I dunno,
I can't tell.
I don't know what the fuck the deal was.
I didn't see a skyline.
It was snowing like I haven't seen it snow in years.
And then I got on a little fucking trolley,
which was really confusing and I went the long way,
like seven times.
But the Saddledome was the shit and I sat next to some guy from Canada who said
a after everything,
you know,
like that strange brew Shit.
Like oh they got to get it out a a means everything up there.
It means,
you know,
it means like,
you know what I'm saying?
It means,
what did you say?
It means how,
I guess that also means what he's,
I don't know,
it's like seven different,
it's like Donnie Brasco when he fucking explained a forget about it.
That's what a is in fucking Alberta.
You've got to get it out.
Hey,
and they all sounded like they almost sound like the fucking Irish.
I don't know what I'm talking about.
But the game was great.
There was a shootout at the end of the game,
a and a panthers one that one,
and then I,
the next fucking day I drove up to Edmonton through towns like the towns out
there and I was looking at the weather map.
It was like a,
you know,
fucking red deer,
yellow knife,
you know those Indian names,
the classic White Guy Thing,
you know,
you murder a bunch of people,
you commit genocide and then you name towns after him,
you know,
did we destroy the,
want the fucking punk upon people.
Let's name a street after him,
maybe even a golf course.
I think that that's only the right thing to do,
considering none of them exist anymore.
Let's do something here to remember these people after we've massacred them and
put small pockets on their phone,
in their sleeping bags.
Did any of have sleeping bags?
I don't think they did.
What did they use for sleeping bags?
Did they sleep in the fucking end trails of an animal like Luke Skywalker?
This podcast went off the rails about fucking two minutes ago cause I got in my
head going,
did I just calm myself down like five minutes ago?
And then all of a sudden I stopped being funny.
I mean his podcast started off great.
I Sang Christmas carols,
you know what I mean?
I defended saying Merry Christmas,
you know,
and then all of a sudden I was like,
wait a minute,
I'm coming off angry,
let's take it down a little bit.
And then all of a sudden I felt like I was doing the traffic.
You know,
I like to traffic down the south when you listen to it.
Cause they,
they,
they still say,
uh,
when there's an accident they call it a wreck.
And that always makes me feel like I'm watching NASCAR.
We've got a lick down there all,
no,
not a farm.
They don't talk like that.
But that's all I hear at that point when someone says,
Libby got a wreck,
there's a car all Tory up on the side of the fucking road.
Um,
and anyways,
then when I drove up,
yeah I was going to stop off in red deer to get something eat to eat just on my
way up to Edmonton just to say I fucking did it.
And then I was like,
you know what,
red deer sounds like it reminds me of one of those,
those A&E murder mystery that I watched where these two hunters had gone up to
some fucking place to go hunting.
They stopped off in a bar,
they exchanged words with people,
they got killed and then somebody in the bar fed their bodies to pigs.
And it was one of the most creepiest fucking stories I've ever seen.
You know,
just that whole fucking feeding them person to pigs and they all look like they
were in like Creedence Clearwater revival.
So it was really fucking with my head.
And um,
I don't know,
red deer just sounded like that kind of shit can happen.
So I bypassed it and I continued on up to Edmonton.
I'm going to tell this story in real time.
Let's fly forward.
Okay?
I had a great time.
Edmonson was an awesome game coming up there and seeing all the championship
banners in the fucking retired jerseys at Gretzky and Messiaen and all you gotta
do it.
Okay.
Not to mention both the Saddledome and Northlands coliseum are just basically a,
I don't know,
they're like no frills.
They made an ice rink and they put seats around it and that's it.
There's no,
uh,
none of that shit.
You know what I mean?
Although,
you know what,
Calgary definitely had the horse skating around on the ice in between and I'm,
Oh God,
what am I get to questions?
I just bored the shit out of myself.
But there was such a fucking good time.
I had an awesome time up there.
You know what it is?
I just,
I woke up at fucking eight in the morning and I just got on a plane and I had to
come back and do the podcast.
So I'm skipping over a bunch of good details.
You know?
What did I see up there?
I saw some guy in like minus 90 million degrees Celsius,
whatever the fuck that is.
I think that's like five degrees American and he was fixing a four wheeler with
no hat on
and no gloves.
You standing out there.
Do you remember Arthur funds a rally used to dress when they gave him a garage,
when they ran out of shit to do with this character.
It was before he became a teacher.
But after him just hanging out at Arnold's when they were finally like,
okay,
this guy's like 30 he needs a job.
You know what I mean?
How does he afford to live in that attic?
He was dressed like that and it was fucking cold out and he was fixing a four
wheeler and I was,
it was,
I actually videotaped it and if I knew how to upload it,
I put it on there.
But anyways,
this is my podcast and we get to the questions here.
People send me questions all this week.
I think I shot my load with that fucking song right up the front,
you know?
And if I sucked the rest of the way out.
You gotta admit three minutes of Christmas.
Carolyn,
isn't that,
am I defending my podcast?
I mean,
this is ridiculous.
Second bombing is a comedian.
Go.
Come on,
man.
No,
no.
It was a funny joke.
Well,
it was funny.
You know,
I mean a,
Hey,
this guy,
you know,
and they set up,
I didn't have any extra words.
I disguise the punchline.
I took a left at the last second.
Can't help if you guys don't want to go along for the ride.
All right,
question number one.
Um,
Bill,
since you're,
you're a struggling actor trying to make it,
have you ever thought about doing gay porn?
You know,
you guys have really been assholes lately,
but you know what?
I'm going to go fucking be a man about it.
Hillary.
Kay.
Let's go.
Since you're a struggling actor trying to make it,
have you ever thought about doing gay porn to make ends meet?
You already have the iconic shaved head and like hockey.
Do you have a shaved head and you like hockey?
You Gay?
Okay.
Speaking of hockey,
Sean Avery is underrated.
Anyone who calls a woman a con and then tells her that he wouldn't even,
I can't read your fucking typing.
He wouldn't come in her face because she's too old.
Is Cool with me.
All right,
let's get back to your first question.
As a struggling,
you have ever thought about doing gay porn?
Obviously?
No.
Um,
what is the worst thing I have considered doing?
I consider doing commercials back when commercials weren't funny.
Remember back in the day,
like 10,
12 years,
10,
12 years ago,
they started to get funny,
but it was that awkward middle ground where,
you know,
you could be in a really funny commercial or you could just be like a budding
into a sandwich.
And then given that look to the camera,
like boil boy,
was that tasty.
You know,
I remember back in the day,
like I,
I refuse to do a commercial because I listened to that Bill Hicks rant about
that.
And then,
then after a while I was like,
why am I making a difficult business even harder?
You know,
granted,
I don't go out for commercial auditions,
but it's not because I'm against doing commercials.
I just don't do commercial additions because I'm lazy.
Plus they're all the way out in Santa Monica and I'm not driving all the way
over there to fucking act like I'm eating a bowl of fruit loops.
I'm not doing that,
you know?
I do have a little pride.
All right,
question number two,
Bill.
Hey,
I'm a big fan of the podcast.
I listened to most of them traveling over the Thanksgiving break.
I did notice that you have a few favorite words and since I lead a sad but etic
life,
I thought it would be funny to count them during last week's podcast.
So here we go.
Okay.
Evidently this is the list of my favorite words and how many times I say them a
cunt.
Three times.
Wow.
That's pretty low.
We are in a recession.
Um,
I don't know.
I said 27 times shit.
I said 42 times.
Fuck,
I said 127 times.
Wow.
How many?
27 times.
Let's do the math there.
That's about three times a minute.
Four times a minute.
Do what?
A half hour podcast.
Wow.
I'm the Wayne Gretzky of the f word.
All right.
Choke out a pheasant.
I say one time.
I said one time.
Okay.
You're Popeye Popeye.
Like bump up,
chuckle to yourself nine times.
Okay.
I don't know if that was interesting to anybody.
That was kind of interesting to me that somebody that fucking lonely.
Um,
all right.
Underrated.
Overrated.
Brendan Frasier.
Oh,
underrate a Brendan Frazier.
Eric Lindros.
When he first came into the league,
completely bald,
Vagina and college are overrated.
I would go with you.
They had the ball.
Vagina is just fucking creepy.
It's really fucking creepy.
Um,
yeah.
Not a fan.
No.
I don't want to go down to a thatched hut either.
Scene.
I don't do this shit.
I'm like,
I'm not taking it in this direction,
goddammit.
Um,
all right.
Three bill.
If you could have one superpower,
what would it be?
Also,
how would you use it?
Um,
would you fight crime?
Would you commit crimes or would you just use it to beat the shit out of people
who heckled you?
Um,
you know,
when I would do,
I would use it to,
uh,
freak people out who had power.
You know,
like,
if I was like,
I mean,
I can't just have one super power.
I gotta have a couple.
Like if I put it this way up,
I was like,
Superman.
I could fly.
I could,
I could see through,
you know,
walls and I was bulletproof.
I would,
yeah,
I would fuck with people who had power.
I'd fly into the Oval Office,
you know,
right in the middle of them talking about shit.
You know,
I'd just be standing outside the window,
you know,
just staring at him like Michael Myers and like Halloween,
I would just do that.
I would just freak people the fuck out.
Um,
I wouldn't use it to fight crime.
I would use it to get to my gigs a little quicker rather than flying southwest.
And I would just wear my superhero outfit the whole week,
you know,
like Steve Martin,
he always wore that white suit.
I would just wear whatever my superhero fucking suit was,
and I just slide at my gigs.
And then I'd fly home,
no security,
no fucking bags.
I'd have a little toothbrush in my utility belt board.
I do with my,
I dunno what I would do with it.
I would fuck with corporations and,
and leaders of the world.
Um,
and all my information would be shit that I read on Youtube and Wikipedia and
uh,
yeah,
that's what I would do.
Um,
wow.
Just no fucking energy this week.
What is wrong with me?
I was so excited about this podcast and I just really feel like this is a bill
borough woefully miscast and the Monday morning podcast.
I'm number six.
Bill,
I was wondering if there are any situations that you steer away from when you
work?
Audiences.
I'm not talking about something as profound as a racial observation,
but any social subjects that crowds really don't respond to or is everything up
for grabs as,
okay.
These,
these are two things.
I don't really do sex,
sex material.
I just feel like the crowd absolutely loses their mind if you talk about sex,
no matter what you're saying.
And I gotta admit,
I always feel a little crude when I'm talking about it.
You know,
even that's why he kind of broke off the whole ball.
The Vagina think it's just,
there's no class,
you know?
I don't know.
It's just crude unless you have a really unique fucking story to tell.
You know,
I'm not like a prude or anything,
but a lot of times like when I go to see movies and you know,
two actors I are having a love scene and then some guy sucking on the girls
titties,
it's ridiculous to me.
I always look at the first like that,
that's not even necessary to moving the story along.
You know,
back in the day they would just show the cup of gold in the room and they would
close the door and then they would just play that saxophone because the Saks
always back in the day,
always meant someone was going to some book.
People were fucking,
that's what the saxophone meant.
It either meant that or someone was going to do a strip striptease and you had
to play with that really fucking wow fucking sound.
And everybody knew that somebody was getting some Dick.
Right.
But you didn't have to show it.
You know,
that was my whole thing with like Brokeback mountain.
I don't love my watching a movie about a couple of gay cowboys,
but I don't want to watch a couple of dudes fucking at 10 you know,
I don't understand that.
And then like what?
That makes me a more comfortable with my sexuality,
cause I look at that,
I gotta admit half the time there's two things that really grossed me out in
movies.
It's like over the top.
Kissing is fucking gross to me and act.
People who eat during scenes,
I don't know if you've,
I've probably talked about,
this is my number one pet peeve in a movie.
Like I've gone out to lunch with people and they're eating and they talk and
they,
they take their moments when to do it.
Something about actors,
the second they're in a movie and they start eating,
they start over acting,
eating.
You only start fucking pointing with bread.
Yeah.
Y'All gonna fucking dude one,
they got shit hanging out of their mouth.
It's like,
dude,
why don't you finish what you're eating,
collect your fucking thoughts,
swallow,
and then present your line.
Okay.
I don't need you.
You fucking sorry.
I don't even,
what the fuck I'm talking about now?
There's two subject.
Okay.
So sex and um,
I don't make fun of a,
the mentally handicapped.
I just don't,
it just crosses the line.
I've done it before in the opion Anthony Show I've piled on,
I've definitely said some shit on stage if it just pops into my head.
But generally speaking,
I don't write bits.
I just don't,
you know,
half of it cause I think,
that's just brutal to me.
And then secondly,
I haven't had any kids yet and I really feel like I'm jinxing myself.
A long time ago I did do comic view and I did do a bit about movies,
about the mentally handicapped.
I don't know if you can find that on youtube.
And uh,
my parents saw it and they weren't happy and I'm still looking for approval.
So I took that to,
I don't know.
There's too many details.
I,
yeah,
those are the two subjects.
I really don't,
I don't do shit like that.
And I also try not to do a stuff that will reinforce more ironic thought,
you know,
as far as like,
uh,
racial shit.
I try not to do that,
but everything else,
yeah,
I don't care other than I really enjoy pissing people off in the crowd,
you know?
Um,
like whatever,
whatever group I was divided,
beg if that Merry Christmas group,
you know,
the people who find that offensive where at my show,
like,
you know,
it would just basically be your duty as a comedian to just make their night as
miserable as fucking possible.
So I'm definitely an asshole.
But yeah,
those are the sex,
sex in the retarded,
right.
There you go.
Those are,
those are the lines.
All right,
number eight,
bill,
do you fish?
Uh,
no I don't.
Occasionally I have,
I've gone fishing,
but now I don't own a rod or a real,
um,
my favorite part of it is going on,
on the boat and hoping to see,
I like looking at wildlife.
I don't like,
uh,
killing it,
you know,
even if the fish,
it just fucking bothers me.
Like,
you know,
there's already dead fish in the supermarket.
Why don't you just eat that?
But then I read all the survival stuff,
like I should know how to do this.
But then you go up deep sea fishing and they fucking do everything for you.
You just sit down.
They're like annual rotten real sir.
They just hand it to you.
They tell you what to do.
They know where to go,
where the fish are.
And it's like,
you know,
you feel like,
I feel like,
you know,
when you're like five years old and your dad lets you sit in his lap and steer
the fucking car and you're like,
Hey,
I'm driving the car.
No,
you're not.
You're fucking child.
Um,
and I also really enjoy the drinking.
Uh,
that's the part of the fishing that I like,
even though boos and boats don't miss mix according to the posters.
All right,
Bill,
who do you think are the top three electrical garter guitarists that are
currently performing?
I have no fucking idea.
I'm 40 years old.
I should know that.
All right.
My favorites of all time.
Or Stevie Ray Vaughan.
And recently I really got back into Jimmy page.
I really got back into his shit and um,
I don't know who the third one is.
Take your pick,
but it's definitely,
I don't like the Steve Vai,
Joe Satriani kind of guys,
those guys who can play really fast,
but it sounds like they're playing on a Casio keyboard.
Um,
I'm not into really fast guys.
I'm into those guys.
You know,
those,
you know those guys,
guys that give you chills.
Speaking of which,
the best part of,
that's what I wanted to,
the best part of the fucking hockey trip that I took was when I went to
Vancouver and they sang Oh Canada and the guy comes out and he sings the first
verse or whatever and then he stops and then he just sort of conducts the crowd
as they sang the second half.
I got literally goosebumps listening to the people up in Vancouver singing o
Canada cause I never heard it sung like that.
You know,
people in America at the hockey games sing o Canada,
the way they sing the fucking national American national anthem in Canada.
There's no passion.
You don't give a fuck.
You know,
you should have heard them sing.
And they were like,
uh,
say can you hello blah blah.
And then they get to this song and they just like,
oh
they fucking,
you know,
milk and every note they're into it.
[inaudible]
all right,
enough thing here.
All right,
bill number nine.
At Caroline's Caroline's show,
you mentioned that your grandmother is 101 years old at her age.
Does she still have any messed up out of date reasonings?
My grandfather is 86.
He's typical old Italian man,
sharp for his age,
but recently in an interracial couple moved next door to him and we had to stop
him from going to city hall because he wanted to have his property taxes lower
due to the fact as he put it,
a colored woman is living next door.
[inaudible] swear to God.
That's true.
No bullshit.
What do you think fucked up fucking classic are a little both.
Um,
that's a hard one.
Obviously,
if somebody you know,
below the age of 60 thinks something like that,
yeah,
that's fucked up.
But um,
I mean the guy's fucking,
let's,
let's do the math here.
He's 86 years old.
All right,
let's smell,
how do we do this?
Here is six plus four is 94 years from now is 2012 so he was born in 1922.
All right.
The guy's born in 19 fucking 22.
Um,
all right.
He's 18 in 1940.
They didn't even let black people in the fucking army when they did,
they put them in a special unit.
It's like fucking 15 years before
when the fuck was civil rights.
No,
it was like 25 fucking years after that.
23.
Yeah.
No,
I mean that's got,
yeah,
that's his wheelhouse.
You know what I mean?
The same way.
I don't know,
like what Best Guitar Star that are playing today.
Cause now I'm 40.
I'm off like you,
you just,
you're,
you're awake.
You shoved off to see,
I got my fucking 10 albums in my head that I'm going to listen to for the rest
of my life.
The same way old people still listen to in the mood that it a debt,
debt,
debt.
They fucking love that song.
I hate that song drives me nuts.
It makes me want to kill somebody.
But when I'm 80,
I'll still be listening to back in black and I think you take how you think
along with you.
So,
um,
I dunno.
And at that point he's 86 is he really gonna start a hate group.
You know,
it's kind of funny.
Racism becomes funny only when you're so fucking old that you couldn't do
anything about it,
you know?
Then you just become this crazy old guy who's just saying a bunch of shit.
So I guess,
yeah,
it is.
That is funny.
But you know,
it's weird.
This is getting back to that with that kid was asking me about what you talk
about right now.
I feel like I have a social responsibility because I'm talking to 14 people over
the goddamn phone to now say that that's fucked up.
Okay.
You know what,
in public on television,
if the guy did that,
that's definitely fucked up.
But sitting in your living room and your grandparents said something fucking
racist.
It's hilarious.
You know,
not cause you can don't it just because they're so uncensored and they don't
give a fuck.
And uh,
yeah,
I probably would've laughed.
I would've left.
I'm not saying I'm condoning it on any level.
All right,
question number 10,
uh,
know what's really,
really overrated.
Oh,
over eight and under eight.
Um,
this assumption that all gay men are funny.
You know what,
that's just hilarious right there because you really do picture them like that.
I've actually said that.
Defense it gay people,
like I don't understand why people have such a problem with them.
You know,
they fucking hilarious and exactly.
I don't want to watch two of them fucking a tent,
you know,
I have my,
but this guy says basically I work in a restaurant,
we have our share,
a gay guys that have a great sense of humor,
but just because you're gay doesn't mean describing what you'd let Clive Owen do
to you in great detail is funny.
Yeah,
that's Kinda nasty.
I've known a couple of gay guys who get a little over the top with the fucking
description of this sexual shit that they want to do.
You know,
it does get creepy,
you know,
but you know what it is.
That's Karma for straight guys because how that makes you feel as a straight
guy.
That's how women feel when you,
when you know,
some girl walks by and you're like,
yeah,
I'd love to fucking been here a little or you know,
whatever.
Fucking Evil Shit you say.
So.
Um,
yeah.
Wow.
That's a lot of awful images in my head.
All right,
let's get to the next one.
Overrated cable TV,
especially the movie channels because they just rerun all the same suck ass
movies like kindergarten,
kindergarten,
cop are under siege.
They still run van Damme movies and the worst are the cheesy pornos.
Um,
yeah.
You know what I gotta admit,
the only reason why I watch a fucking movie TV is just to watch the fights.
And I watched that show.
Dexter,
is anybody even still listening to this podcast?
I'm so fucking jet lag right now from flying to seeing three hockey games and
three nights I think.
I feel like I'm just a,
I'm reading like the fucking stock report.
All right.
Underrated.
Oh,
this should wake you up.
The sex swing.
The sex swing is underrated.
Really?
I didn't know people were out there.
[inaudible] think fucking blows or maybe you're saying it's underrated because
no one really talks about it.
Okay.
Let's hear the review.
The sex swing.
Really,
I'm not trying to be scandalous or anything.
Um,
if this is something people have not yet tried,
for Christ's sake,
try it.
I promise.
It makes it fun and easy to fuck.
Yes.
Because the rest of us find it tedious
and not fun.
You know what?
That's the way you should,
you know what?
I think that that's,
uh,
the sex swing should be for old people who get Viagara and they still want to
fuck.
All right.
Oh Wow.
I just said I wasn't going to do sex material,
but you really just fucking,
you know,
he just fucking lobbed it over and that,
okay,
this is what you do.
Okay.
You fucking lube up grandma.
All right.
Not Grandma your wife.
Now.
It's really disgusting.
All right.
You fucking take a little by Agra
and then you just push her away.
Like just when you like a little kid,
you just push,
your wage keeps coming to you.
Ah,
and then you just push her away again.
Whew.
All right.
You fucking bag away.
And what else?
What if you am pregnant?
You know,
Sherry,
you'd be dead by the time the kids fucking in kindergarten,
but you know,
yeah,
you'll fucking be on good day America.
They think of that act like it was cute.
Like when Tony Randall had a kid at 72.
Oh that Tony and Tony fucking Randall,
you don't,
even if you have a kid at 72,
you know,
especially if it's a boy,
what you basically just had is a future felon.
All right?
Because the fucking confusion of having a 72 year old gay man is your dad who
dies when you're in the fourth grade.
You know,
at the very least,
you know you're going to rob a convenience store.
I don't know that I was just,
that was really,
I thought it was a,
that was an asshole move on his part and I've never been able to enjoy the odd
couple the way I used to.
Um,
all right.
All right.
Overrated.
I like this one.
This is a great one song.
This is overrated songs for causes.
You know those hacky collaboration's with a bunch of stars in the same studio.
I'm,
you're a singer.
Lead the life and death shit to someone else.
All right.
That's sort of a two part thing there.
I hate songs for causes.
Um,
I didn't mind that we are the world kind of Shit just because that actually
seemed like a,
there was so many people involved that no one really got the credit.
But like,
um,
you know,
when all those rednecks will make on those,
let's go to war song songs and protect the boys.
Those songs were really,
really fucking cheesy.
Oh,
is that Warren and Uncle Sam's going to put a boot in your ass or whatever the
fuck that one was.
I was just really one of the most ignorant songs I think I've ever heard.
And uh,
and plus,
you know,
like who the fuck is not gonna like a song that says,
support the troops and let's go fuck up some people.
I guess they've always done that.
Right?
The bogo Boogie Woogie bugle boy.
Remember that?
About the name of the day,
the DAB at that.
All right.
Um,
and you said you were a singer.
Leave the life and death shit to someone else.
I disagree with that.
I don't think just because you're in the public eye,
therefore you shouldn't talk about who you vote for or you shouldn't have
opinions.
All right?
Be honest with yourself.
All right,
the F,
there's every bar.
You walk into this,
people talking politics,
they're talking life and death shit.
People sitting there going,
dude,
you know,
we should know.
You know,
we should write some fucking more on down the end of the bar.
You listen to him,
you'll actually fucking wait until he's finished.
You'll never call him a moron,
but then all of a sudden you have a fucking hit song and you,
you don't want to hear somebody talking about it.
You know what it is.
This is what it is.
I should've just said,
this is what it is.
Rather than go,
you know what it is.
All right.
I'm like,
you could actually respond to me.
It's the fact,
it's very hard to do stuff like that without coming off as preachy.
And um,
that's another thing in my act that I tried to never do.
I never use the word we because I saw a comedian do it one time and it annoyed
the shit out of me.
He was like,
do we do this now?
We want a country where we a blind.
I immediately was like,
dude,
I want to fucking choke you.
I'm with the Mike Court.
Oh God.
Just the references are just done flying out.
You know?
That's really is a train wreck.
This is like a,
what was that?
What was that fucking album that,
that dude,
I'd not from the beach boys never put up.
What was it called?
A fucking pet sounds.
It finally,
finally just put it out when he was just going nuts.
This is my podcast version of this.
I'm saw that let George Michael one where he's just like,
I'm not going to be in the videos dialing.
I'm just going to put other people in and I want the music to stand on itself,
and then his career just takes a fucking nose dive.
It's like,
listen.
Um,
Okay.
Even gay or Tom Cruise,
if you're not,
if you're not fucking wearing shaking your ass in the TV with your little
fucking stupid little scruff going,
nobody gives a fuck.
You know?
I know I didn't give a fuck as much.
I was like,
if I couldn't see George Michael's ass,
um,
he would.
That was a very confusing artists for me cause I really liked how we sang on
some songs.
Um,
like when he redid that Elton John Song,
he fucking destroyed it.
But he was just so fucking a feminine.
It just made me uncomfortable.
You know,
if he just said,
listen,
I'm gay and I just got done blowing somebody and I'd really love to do it again,
that would destroy the tension.
And he'd be like,
okay,
he's out in the open and then he can laugh about it.
You know,
he did I just blow somebody and I was singing a song,
oh,
I'm going to guy.
But it's a fact that he doesn't bring it up and how we singing.
And occasionally,
you know,
he does a little fucking twinkle toes move.
It just makes it fucking uncomfortable and very hard to enjoy the music.
All right.
Another thing that is underrated,
a good waiter and or bartender,
um,
just some guys really good at his job,
especially when you don't have to ask him for anything.
And he's right on top of it.
Absolutely.
Like the fucking waiters in the bartenders over at Smith and one Lidsky.
You ever want to go there and have a fucking professional waiter?
Slash.
Bartender?
I told you guys I was over there last,
I was just fucking great.
You felt like a god to him.
It felt like you were really in the rat pack,
but he was dressed nice.
Um,
get married.
Let people know you're not a homo.
Um,
thanksgiving,
uh,
is overrated.
A day involved with nothing but gorging yourself and watching high school and
pro football,
junk food,
breasts,
breakfast,
cereals,
overrated.
I don't know about you,
but a bowl of fruity pebbles or cookie cookie crisp is just as good when you
first wake up as when you shit faced.
You know what?
I gotta agree with you,
but I would definitely go with fruity pebbles,
cookie crisp and captain crunch.
You know,
as much as I liked him as a kid.
Do you ever get a mouthful of those things and you that when you bite down,
there's like three of them.
One of them,
just one of them turned sideways on your tongue and it misses your teeth and it
hits the roof of your mouth.
I mean,
dude,
that is a fucking pain.
Like,
I mean in Guantanamo they should do that.
They should fucking put fucking Coco Crisp on fucking people's tongues and make
them bite down.
You get all the information you want.
I don't like those series.
I don't like cereals that,
you know,
are they going on the outside of your teeth and they go right up in between.
You know that that skin that covers your teeth,
whatever.
That's I guess that's called your face.
Yeah.
Gets,
gets underneath that,
you know,
and just fucking drives it in there.
And then that night you forget that you did it,
then you're brushing your teeth and of course the toothbrush goes off your teeth
and goes right into that raw fucking place.
I don't like those series fruity pebbles.
I like,
what else do I like?
You know,
fruity pebbles is one of the few ones.
I don't get that fucking crazy with breakfast series.
I like it.
I like classics.
Cheerio's raisin brand,
grape nuts flakes.
I like great nuts.
You know,
and I know you think,
okay,
those things are so granulated,
they can't cut,
cut up your fucking mouth.
I really have to end this podcast.
I gotta apologize to you guys.
One of the worst podcasts I've had.
I've just,
you know,
probably nine times during this podcast have literally just kinda come to
feeling like I passed out for three minutes and I know I continued talking,
so I apologize for any photo and any sort of,
I can't even talk with them.
Me,
I said any Fordham instead of any sort of,
alright,
here we go.
Let's get,
let's,
let's wrap this up bill and get on with it.
Okay.
Um,
another thing,
overrated.
Uh,
a doodle as the balls to wear for that is fucking hilarious.
All right,
here's a story.
I saw a guy the other day wearing a full length raccoon coat and it looked so
fucking bad ass.
And the best part was that he also had the fox head scarf to go with it.
Maybe you want to get one of my own.
You know what?
That's fucking hilarious.
There's not enough people out there dressed like fur trappers,
you know,
that's also,
because that's,
that's one of those things like merry Christmas now it's just become taboo to
wear for,
which,
you know,
I wouldn't wear for,
but uh,
you know,
I would never,
spray ketchup at somebody who was wearing a all of a sudden pheasant.
I almost said a pheasant.
That really is my default animal,
isn't it?
God dammit.
You know what?
Whoever wrote that in,
you got me.
You got one of my ticks.
We played poker.
You'd know exactly what my hand was.
Um,
all right.
One more overrated,
underrated Sidney Crosby of the Pittsburgh Penguins.
And Am is overrated is hype of being the next one in hockey.
I'm so fucking sick and tired of hearing this out be it,
it's died down the past year.
Hearing that he's the next [inaudible] I'm sick of hearing that he's next.
The next Greski he's not.
Um,
yeah,
well I mean that's Kinda like,
that's not his fault,
dude.
That's because everyone wants someone to be the next Gretzky.
You know,
he's not writing the articles.
That's like after Michael Jordan retired,
there was a nice,
you know,
there's always going to be that hangover and saying someone's going to be the
next fucking Jordan because you want to see it and I ain't going to happen.
Um,
and I think,
uh,
that's it.
Some quick ones.
Underrated or overrated,
underrated.
Vinyl.
Overrated.
The compact disc.
Um,
I think compact this or underrated,
you know,
all you people going out,
they just get your music digitally and then what happens?
You fucking iPod dies and you lose your entire collection.
I've talked about this.
You want the comp.
Having a compact disc is like having the gold behind your paper money.
All right?
You need to back up your digital shit cause it's not worth anything compact.
This are tangible.
You have the vinyl,
definitely underrated.
It definitely gets hot and sticky in the sun,
but if you spill something,
it's very easy to clean and a,
that's it.
That's still your Monday morning podcast for this week.
I really apologize for being so fucking jet lag.
I hope I can get some sort of points for getting right off the Goddamn plane and
um,
you know,
doing the project.
Jesus Christ.
Listen to me.
Just family.
I'm like a fucking old woman.
Um,
all right here.
Here we go.
What do I have the hype here?
I'm literally taking off my hooded sweatshirt.
That's how right in the door.
I was when I fucking started doing this podcast.
Um,
I am going to be,
I'm going to be,
let me get on the fucking website here.
If you're still hanging in here,
I really should send you some sort of a gift.
Uh,
would you like to hear another holiday song?
And it's like fucking a,
I don't know the words.
You know,
you don't mind mother fucking holiday song I hate the most is silver belts.
It's just the sum of about the tempo or that song just sucks the life out of the
lower half of my body and I just have to,
you know,
it always comes on when I'm in the mall and I really just don't want to shop
anymore and it just comes on Silverado silver
[inaudible] that one.
And I don't like a Jingle Bell Rock.
I hate any sort of jazzing up
[inaudible] jingle bell rock POW Jenga Bell time.
Yeah.
I fucking hate that song.
And I hate that Michael Jack Jackson.
Santa Claus is coming to town.
I hate the way he phrases it and I know I'm making fun of a fucking seven year
old and I should just be happy that he was able to go into the studio and
perform that day.
But I didn't
shut the fuck.
Just shut up Michael,
the seven year old.
You pleased you shut the fuck up.
I hate that song.
I really hate that song.
Um,
I like the classic slower once the Bing Crosby once.
Does anybody care?
All right.
I'm on my website.
Ah,
my,
when he got here.
All right.
I'm in January.
I'm taking a break until January.
I right.
Uh,
I fuck with January 8th.
I'm already back out on the road.
Wait,
what's today?
The 15th is 60 more days.
16 I didn't get three weeks off the fuck am I bitching about can we just people
out there churning butter?
I like Ahmad going to be at the Improv in Tampa,
Florida.
January 8th,
ninth and 10th now.
I haven't been there in a long fucking time and uh,
that they'd scare the shit out of me because,
um,
Florida is a crazy animal man.
I don't know what to do with it.
I don't know how to sell tickets and Florida,
I've gone down there.
I've done what I can fucking do.
And I,
right now I have people around the country or like why speaking in that redneck
fucking southern voice.
You talking about Florida,
Florida's and part of the south.
Yes it is.
If you get out of Miami,
that entire,
that entire state is,
is,
you know,
you could film
400 seasons of cops,
dog,
the Bonnie Hunter.
And if you ever really,
you know,
look at Dexter.
Dexter is his fucking tape down there,
right?
Isn't it Miami vice splitting.
My told me that.
What do they have on those tee shirts down there?
Florida.
Uh,
what do they call it?
A cool place for shady,
something like that.
Hot Place for shady people too.
One of those play on words.
I'm not good at that shit.
All right.
I'm going to be at the Improv Tam in Tampa on January 8th,
ninth and 10th and a Oh and January 8th is the show your tits show.
Just to let you know,
uh,
that's something new that that's an added on to do with me.
You know,
I'm actually against it.
I don't want girls to show me their titties during my show,
you know,
but you know,
it's something that the Improv's are coming up with.
You know,
I think it's sexist,
but you know,
I don't want to cause any static.
So,
you know,
just know that when you're showing me your tips during that show that uh,
there wasn't my call.
Uh,
I don't condone it,
but I was powerless to stop it.
So,
you know,
yeah,
I guess I'll go along with it.
I'll sign some titties after the show,
you know,
show me a phone.
I mean,
whatever you mean.
I mean I'm just there for the art,
you know.
Okay.
Uh,
and then after that I'm going to be at the Improv in Houston,
Texas.
January 22nd,
23rd and 24th.
I really excited to go back to that one because I'm,
I'm actually going to hit this guitar store out there called South Park Guitars.
They have nothing but lefthanded guitars there and I'm going to go there and
spend some money,
mother fucker.
Um,
after that.
And we had the Wilbur Theater in Boston and the comedy connection in Chickopee,
Massachusetts February 6th through the seventh.
And that is that wow.
47 minute podcast.
That's how fucking jet lag that was.
I knew I just fell asleep for like 10 minutes in the middle of that.
I apologize.
This is way too fucking long.
Um,
everybody have a merry Christmas.
Okay?
And I mean that in a nice way.
Heaven.
Merry Christmas.
Even if you're not fucking celebrating Christmas,
have a fucking merry Christmas.
God Damn.
It's not a bad thing.
It's not a real,
some fucking real.
How did that become bad?
I don't know.
Bill,
why don't you fucking analyze it for another 47 minutes.
All right,
I'm outta here.
Um,
God bless all of you.
I'll talk to you next Monday.
Have a great [inaudible].
Okay.
Take it easy again.
Took a deep breath.
I fell down.
I could not stand captain a Ram.
He started writing up some needs he said was set up for right here.
I find a place with beads.
Then his cop homes down the street.
Crazy as alone and throws us all in jail for Carrion.
Huh?
Mia Bust,
busted out.
Don't even asked me how I went to get some help.
I walk by and Guernsey cow who directed me down to the Bowery slums where people
carried signs around saying,
Ban the bombs.
I realized right away and I said,
I hope that I'm not late.
When I realize I hadn't eaten for five days.
I went to restaurants looking father told him I was the editor of a famous ed to
get the the waitress.
He was handsome.
He wore a powder blue Cape and some Suzette.
I said,
could you please make that great?
Justin Lowe kitchen exploded from boiling fat.
Food was frying everywhere.
I left with that hat.
Didn't mean to be nosy,
but I went into it.
Bank did get some feel for a rab and all the boys back in the tank.
They asked me for collateral,
pulled down my pants.
They threw me in the alley,
went up,
comes this girl from France who invited me to her house.
I went,
but you had a friend who are not my boots and I was on the street again.
[inaudible].
Then I wrapped up on at her house with the u s flag upon display.
I said,
could you help me out?
I got some friends down in the wait,
the man says,
and get out of here,
Terry,
you them from them.
I've said,
you know,
they refuse Jesus to the city or not him out of here before I break your phones
ain't your pop.
I decided to have him arrested and I went looking for a
[inaudible].
Well ran outside and I hopped inside a cab.
I went up the other door,
this Englishman,
stiff fam as he saw me leave a hotdog stand in,
a cheery in that stood,
walked across from the building advertising brotherhood.
I ran right through the front door
[inaudible],
but it was just a funeral planner and the man asked me who I was.
I repeated that my friends were all in jail with a sigh.
They gave me his card.
He said,
call me if they died.
I shook his hand and said goodbye and ran up to the street when a bowling ball
came down the road and knocked me off my feet.
The pay phone was ringing.
Just about blew my mind when I picked it up and said,
hello,
if foot game through the line
[inaudible].
By this time I was fed up at trying to make it stab at bringing back some help
from my friends and captain,
a rat.
I decided to flip a coin,
either hips of chills would let me know if I should go back to the ship or back
to jail.
So sealer suit.
Matt got a crime to flip.
It came up,
tails around with.
So I made it back in the shit.
When I got back and took the parking ticket off the mask,
I was ripping it to shreds.
When his coast guard boat went past,
they asked me [inaudible] name and I said,
Captain Kid,
they believe me.
But they wanted to know what exactly that I did.
I said,
for the Pope of you route,
I was employed.
They let me go right away.
They were very pan or
[inaudible].
Well,
the last I heard of a rabbi,
he was stuck on a whale that was married to the deputy sheriff of the jail.
But the funniest thing was when I was leaving the baby as far three ships
sailing,
and
I asked the captain what his name was and have come,
he didn't drive a truck.
Niece's name was Columbus.
Good luck.
[inaudible].